Yes,
my knife all day.
That's it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're live,
we're live with two fucking psychopathic car fanatics here
in the,
the,
the lovely valley of Los Angeles.
Magnus Walker.
And of course my friend Alex Ross from shark works who,
uh,
I drove his car yesterday.
I know you've driven his,
his new creation.
That is without a doubt the scariest car I've ever driven.
It wasn't the best environment for it cause it was on the canyons and it's got
so much power.
You,
you can't really use it on those canyons because it's just so by the time you
hit the gas,
you're hitting the breaks.
Like you hit the gas you get,
it's like something around 800 horsepower around there.
Yep.
Give or take depending.
Well gas he used and like 3,200 pounds,
31 3,100 pounds.
That's fucking ridiculous.
It's like a factory sort of gt three weight with 800 horsepower,
you know,
go up to talk about,
six 50 to the wheels and until you're bouncing off the revolution,
uh,
you know,
second,
third gear,
second gear on the limited who's 87 miles an hour.
Third was a buck 25 and then by the time he deep in a fourth,
he just sorta running out a road.
And if you,
have you done a top speed on that car yet you attempted it?
Yes.
Well,
officially we saw a one 47 somewhere yesterday and we were not out of fourth
gear,
so it's probably gotta be close to 200 well over 200.
Actually.
The way that kit works,
um,
it's already just in a turbo car.
It already does about 202 in the mile.
So in a lighter two wheel drive car,
it's about that.
I mean,
it'll trap one 40 in the quarter.
Easy.
It's like a,
it does everything.
You know,
who know,
there's always this thing about cars where people always want to add more power.
And as you guys both know,
we're in this weird horsepower war now in the world where every year cars have
to,
if you have a car that makes 400 horsepower next year,
it's got to at least make a little more 400 horsepowers like a Camry right now.
Right.
Well how about that BMW m three that I have,
which is a pretty moderate car,
420 horsepower.
Let me tell you the craziest thing that I did recently.
Last year in July,
I went to Norway to the gap bowl festival.
I don't know if you've heard of these things,
know how to describe it.
It was like Mad Max meets burning man on steroids and it's essentially a DIY
drift fest,
but essentially these guys,
800 to a thousand horsepower and a Volvo wagon and they're drifting sideways
around the whole track.
So yeah,
the days of 400 horsepower sorta been a benchmark,
a Gumbo.
I'm sort of the opposite.
I'm the lessees Morga you know?
Yeah.
Well that's what I wanted.
I thought it was interesting that you take these really cool old classic nine
11th,
and if you haven't seen the documentary urban outlaw,
you gotta check it out.
It's just so,
what is it about 30 plus minute,
two minutes short documents in a May?
It really got me excited about those old cars.
It's an amazing documentary.
And you don't,
one of the things that you said,
we,
we down already
with the audio.
Yeah.
We'll,
we'll work it out.
Um,
we,
we have a new setup here.
This is completely new to
being at NASA or over here.
Well,
that's all.
This is a new thing called a tri caster and it does everything in HD,
but we haven't worked out all the kinks yet.
Is it?
It's on recording.
You mean we're not shooting this on an iPhone?
I'm sure we'll hear about it on reddit and everyone the audio back up.
But as the audio up,
let me hear.
Hold on.
Yeah,
it's work.
There you go.
You know why often the corner has got an iPhone.
You can take some great shots with that bag.
Ralph,
Ralph's ready to rock your,
uh,
your documentary about those old classic nine 11,
and you know,
you rebuild them and add your own touches to them,
but,
but your car is,
you know,
you're,
you're working with some of them less than 200 doors.
Yeah,
I mean,
most of my calls a small displaced,
you know,
for those that don't know my collections,
basically early nine 11,
it's from 64 through [inaudible] 73,
you know,
I'm not really just covers to lead up to two full unlike this mad dog in English
men right here,
Alex.
Well,
you know,
too much.
He's never enough.
My background was sort of the opposite,
you know,
it was more of the sort of giant killer.
Trying to chase down the cars with twice as much power,
uh,
was to me a bit more exciting rather than just sort of,
you know,
Florida and a straight line and you can still get a lot done if a costs set up
pretty well.
Cause two 77 that's a car I've tracked on an off for 12 years and a lot of uh,
club racing stuff and he's so dialed in that 220 horsepower is pretty usable in
a car that only ways they say 20 to 50 wait is such a key to what I call a flat
foot Chi.
You can keep your foot planted all the time,
unlike the gt two,
as great as that is,
you got to roll into that amount of power because if he just stump it,
you just spin in the road.
It's almost too much power.
I mean he'd stop.
I think the challenge is there,
he's trying to build to modulate and actually get that power down is takes a
little bit of finesse cause she sort of got a role into it cause traction
control on or off.
If you stamp it,
he sorted as the same thing.
He just chirping and spinning and stepping sideways.
Well,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but the traction control did they calculated based on the horsepower of the
engine actually has.
So when you jam it up to,
it's not just traction,
it's a stability management.
It was the first time on a 907 that it had well on a gt car.
So your car being an you know,
oh seven oh eight mark one,
it actually has like a,
uh,
a more simple traction control system that,
you know,
you can,
you can turn off.
Um,
but it doesn't have stability management like the gt two.
So it actually has two buttons.
One is,
you know,
are you fucking nuts?
You're going to fucking die in right now.
So,
yeah.
So is that on the button or it just,
his passed on was,
it says like s c plus TC equals death,
right?
Like no
orange light comes on,
you know?
Yeah.
You,
you know,
it's sort of like,
it gives you a chime as if you've got a problem with your engine.
You know,
that same like if you have a check engine light on a car,
you know,
you just got this thing and you like,
you're driving and you have this like,
you know,
orange amber warning sign.
So it's,
it's you,
they're pretty to
the old cars have none of that crap,
you know,
you do.
So that feeling or you don't feel it,
I just,
especially with the brakes,
right.
You,
you actually can modularly,
yeah.
Pushing them hard.
Yeah.
No power assisted small.
What's happened to the brakes on the gt two are almost the same size as the
wheels on two 77,
14 and a half,
15 inch,
80 million.
So yeah,
they're almost the same size.
They're 15 inch brakes,
15 inch wheels,
and those are 15 x breaks.
Well,
you need it with that car.
And most people aren't aware of how much computer generated stuff is going on
behind the scenes of a lot of these modern high powered horse cars.
Like I got to drive the challenger Hellcat recently and all that stuff.
Even though it's 770 horsepower,
it's very manageable when you're driving it around because they have all this
stuff going on behind the scenes.
There's always a pug.
I still got my,
uh,
69 superbeets that,
well,
there's a,
that's a mopar to be proud of.
This folly
is the valet key,
like special for the fire.
Yeah,
they give you that.
But I told them I don't even want that
stupid.
Why should they have 500 got caught.
You caught it.
But if you leave a valley guy with a 500 horsepower car,
he could kill himself a wrapping around and shake just as easily 700 horsepower
car.
It's pretty funny for folks who don't know what we're talking about.
There's two different keys.
One is a red key and one's a black key.
The red key gives you full access to all the power,
which gets you up to hell cat,
707 horsepower somehow or another.
Just having the black key limits,
the amount of horsepower.
Yeah,
well it just doesn't end probably controls it controls,
you know,
throttle mapping and not as much black metal.
You know,
an amount of uh,
yeah,
it's probably just a throttle map controller and you know,
obviously you know,
it doesn't allow you to sort of dig deeper and go higher up.
He said,
well there's a big,
there's a lot of rev limitations.
Even when you just wrapped the car up just to have some fun with it feels
sloppy.
Well it just backs off when you get up near anywhere near the red line like you,
you,
you feel it cutting out.
I think in the moral to the story is never let a valet guy knew you car.
Really that is the moral is good.
We don't need two keys and I've never let any valet touching my GED.
I had it valet key with one of the first cars I had,
which was you know like in at the end of 19 nine it was a supercharged Jaguar
XKR and it was a convertible best of British two vertebral total California car.
That when you were doing all that modeling and you were telling me about that
was that was a lot longer supermodel.
Yeah.
Early Internet celebrity.
Did you know that about him?
A gamer you,
I don't know.
Do you remember?
Do you remember websites like Tom's hardware and non tech?
Sharkey extreme was mine and that was one of the big three.
And then food or extreme was another one that started,
did I remember that?
I remember since the men,
and I remember I started reading the map behind the shocked about this before.
I don't know if we talked about it on the podcast.
We've definitely talked about it before.
That was your background.
I was a student video gamer.
I was trying to make some money.
So I started writing for
magazines and this is back in England and uh,
they would go,
why you want to write about,
you know,
hardware in three d cards and all this shit's never going to work.
And so I just started posting it on the Internet instead and I moved out here
and you know,
sold a website that was big during the Dotcom era.
He's a funny little bit thought it.
That's one of those things where people thought there was no market for it.
People thought,
Nah,
no one's going to pay attention to that APP.
But you could put it on the Internet and you put it on the Internet.
It becomes giant.
Well,
obviously there's a market,
just you fuck heads couldn't figure out how to reach that market.
Remember this crazy thing in 1999 y two k like it's going to melt down.
I mean it's amazing.
I didn't fucking meltdown.
How about again in 2012 everybody thought
they were right.
The stars are going to lie,
it's going to last or is up there.
Yeah,
those are fake though.
Photographs.
But you know,
you grow up in England and you,
you know,
cause well there's this big divide basically between north,
south,
north,
south divide.
So you've probably seen those snatch and lock stock and
ferries.
Northern monkeys,
Ella or it's like American being in the eight one eight two,
one three,
two.
One is the south.
And then as the norm
grew up in the Ritzy,
cool park,
which is a south,
I was grim northern Steeltown chef.
Right.
But even in the south,
you know,
if you said,
um,
you know,
to your school counselor or career person,
I want to be a fucking astronauts.
There'd be like tone it down a bit,
you know,
or I want to be a baker now.
You can't do that son,
you know,
just,
uh,
get a normal job.
Yeah.
Talking about America,
I used to hear cut your hair and get a real job.
I was into heavy metal.
I've had long hair since I was 14,
15.
And you know,
over 30 odd years later,
I still got long hair.
But you got more than long hair,
man.
You've got a whole ecosystem.
And I,
you know,
had you got some crazy extra long like rope,
like things I hang out of the car though,
that's epic getting caught in the door.
I was telling these guys,
one of my funniest moments was at the Frankfurt auto show.
Him Push her debut at the nine 18 last year and it was literally 10 minutes
after debuted all the press was uh,
and the invite me up on stage and you get in this nine 18,
and I get my hair caught in the door next day.
There's like headlines in the newspaper.
So subtitle,
he read something like English born American rock star gets her hair caught in
nine 18 door at Frankfurt auto show.
But for me it's sort of like the Samsung thing where you know,
I'm afraid to cut my hair because I'll lose my strength.
But now it's just turning gray and getting thinner and fallen out.
But I've had a long career for 30 years.
But if I was bald on top of,
you're going to keep it on the side.
It'll be like a Nashville posts.
Have you ever seen that band?
You know where the guy takes his hat off and he's like completely bald on the
top and it'll be like that.
But I think the point I was making is England is a sort of class divided
country.
Whereas coming to America,
for me at 19
you could sorta be whatever class divided even in the south.
I mean when you come from England,
I mean let's face it,
we don't have much of a space program.
We don't have,
I mean,
you know,
no career person is going to teach
you guys do
with you.
You son of a bitch.
You carry those things everywhere.
Everywhere,
everywhere.
Dude,
man,
they don't think that Dick's,
but they did the shorts.
Well,
I have a good friend from Steve.
Uh,
his name is Steve and he's from England as well.
And he must know,
he tells me the same thing.
He's actually a professor Steve.
Yeah,
Buddy John.
He's a professor at Stanford and um,
he says essentially the same thing.
He says that when you are in England,
they sort of limit what your aspirations should be.
They tell you where to go.
They tell you what to do.
I mean,
I literally went up to the biggest magazines and um,
you know,
Ralph in the background.
Yeah.
But it's distracting the image.
It's distracting.
Yeah.
We're not his kneecaps caps.
I mean,
if you could sit,
you can sit over here,
you could do whatever you want.
You can join in if you like.
Should we get him some long pants?
He kept saying the background.
We'd do it in the background when the image.
Um,
but just so you know,
he,
he used to work for a very famous Porsche race team.
He used to godfather the Godfather.
He used to work for foster check Polak and he was parking like rs [inaudible]
and moving all these multimillion dollar cars.
That
colors of your 3.9 years.
Yeah,
he is like right off to Kermit.
That's right.
And uh,
and he's also,
he's also barefoot and he drives barefoot cause he can heal.
Untie the gas station in downtown actually.
Yeah.
You want to sit in here?
No,
you're good.
Okay.
We know he's cool.
He's very cool.
He's,
he's the lessees mall guy.
My friend Steve Hilton,
who he's a professor at Stanford is a very interesting guy.
Fascinating guy.
And He fucking loves America.
And he said he didn't realize how negative and how limiting the attitudes of
people in England are until he got to America.
When America people like,
yeah,
you could do whatever you want to do,
whatever you want to do.
No,
literally,
I think I told you this on the last one,
but I went to the most academic ritzy school.
I don't know how the hell I got in there.
A lot of hard work and you know,
my mom started good.
Looks stunning.
Yeah.
Um,
and when I did get there,
I mean,
the whole time it's sort of,
you know,
no,
just keep it down son.
Keep it down.
You know,
don't,
don't just try and do something different.
This is what you need to do.
You need to do this,
this,
and this,
and then you'll,
you'll get a job in the city.
There's no such thing as dare to be different.
Then I left school at 15.
I don't want you left school,
but I don't even know
I was the momentum of ancient times.
It's
just,
it's just them and you know,
you don't want to make him go down this path.
Imagine going to the biggest,
you know,
gaming magazines,
well,
whatever.
If you're a nerd,
um,
gaming magazines and PC magazines back in the 90s and saying,
hey,
there's this really cool new technology that I'm playing with and it's sort of
early on.
I know,
but it's going to make all these video games better.
And then,
you know,
the editor in chief,
he's been there since,
you know,
1985 just goes,
Nah,
that's not going to work.
I'm not doing that.
And so you've got nowhere to like express,
you know,
something cool and new.
So yeah,
the Internet was pretty fricking amazing for me.
You know,
I just threw it up there and then people start reading it and you know,
then what's funny is that same,
that same company,
the publishing company tried to buy my website like fucking four years later and
I said no,
I sold it to internet.com or see something similar in America where the Midwest,
and there's a lot of parts of this country that don't have urban centers and
don't have,
there's a lot of people that are there that have like really limited ideas of
how people should act,
how people should dress,
what people should do,
what religions you should follow.
And because of the Internet w there's like this embedding of like a new culture
in all of these areas.
Like you'd go to anywhere,
you can go to the Midwest,
he can go to Kansas,
you can go and you'll find really fucking cool.
Kids who are on the ball will understand what's going on.
We used to have to go to a library to find anything out or to exist anymore.
Yeah,
they do.
I take my kids to know what did do you do with them there?
They look at a little kid books,
man,
like dinosaur books.
Those on the web because we were talking about magazines and where do you get
them?
It's like the Arab was still,
she's sort of hard to find them.
Yeah.
We're talking about buy magazines at the airport it seems he's got a lot of
them.
Yeah.
A lot of bookstores are dying out and then everything,
all the Porsche magazines and stuff,
they're all like,
you know,
on the iPad now.
You know,
my mom's like better on the IPAD.
Yeah,
he's got an iPhone and snapping photos.
I mean I've sort of,
because I'm an ex,
you know magazine guy too.
I just,
there's something about reading it on paper.
I still,
you know,
I still want to cut down trees,
I guess to do it,
but you know,
I got a great photo of him.
The tree hug,
a photo outside in the rain.
You're not Doug's in English man.
Hugging the trees,
humping your tree.
Sorry,
it's just controlling side.
I just rent here.
Just wipe it clean.
But it is amazing that the Internet offers up all these opportunities and the
Internet is essentially how I found out about both of you guys.
I found out about you because of the urban outlaw documentary,
which is,
look,
how else would you have ever watched that documentary if it wasn't like that
came out of left field?
I mean,
if I can talk about that for a minute too.
uh,
I got to give props to,
to me and Moscow vici my Canadian bid.
Oh Buddy.
Who to,
he'd been fallen my post on Pelican Paltz and I was starting to get a little bit
of magazine coverage probably three years ago.
And pelican parts for folks who don't know the website or the sort of classic
pull should go to a online forum and Paul supply place and many Anna,
right?
A thread going,
the cold Porsche collection out of control hobby.
And Tamir was a Canadian film director who was sort of dissatisfied with doing
bud light commercials.
More importantly,
he was a poor Sharona and sort of connected with my story and figured maybe
there's a little bit more to it than it'd been told through my posts.
And uh,
talking to the internet shot me an email and a couple of emails later we had a
sort of a online verbal handshake and he flew down on his frequent flyer miles
to la,
hired a sort of very talented crew for nothing.
And from my point of it was like,
what's the worst that can happen here?
I'm going to drive around for four days and get some great footage.
We didn't know what was going to happen with that film,
you know.
And uh,
we released a trailer,
probably we shot,
we shot it in 2012 January,
released a trailer a couple of months later that got picked up by top gear and
that things sort of went viral and exploded.
And then the film came out October 15th Online and got into the raindance film
festival and just sort of went from there.
You know?
And it's amazing how global that thing became.
Cause I think people connected to the story,
you know,
the film urban outlaw is not purely about Porsche.
It's about my story of following my dream,
which everyone can relate to.
And we touched on a little bit growing up in England and then coming to America
was in 19 year old,
not knowing anybody but just sorta following your passion and my theory is
always the same.
How bad can it be?
And that's ultimately the great thing about America.
And I think that's what to me are captured in the film.
Urban outlaw was my sort of spirit,
which is a common spirit of trying to,
you know,
follow your dreams and do what it is you like to do without taking no for an
answer.
In the past two years since that film came out,
you know,
it's just been a whirlwind of travel for me and meeting great people.
And I've realized the sort of common bond with all car guys,
it doesn't matter whether you're driving a 800 horsepower gt two or beaten a
building,
a VWD back a yard or you're a mopar guy.
We all share that same common bond of loving to tinker with cars,
like getting out and driving and basically trying to express yourself through
the styling of the car and the passion of the car and everything that it
evolves.
And it is a language,
you know I say Porsche is a language,
but I think all car guys share that same common bond.
And I think that's the connection why people sort of related to the film.
Well your,
your passion and your enthusiasm is really addictive.
And that's one of the things I love about people were in the,
I watched a documentary recently,
short piece on a guy who makes knives.
He makes like three nights.
No,
I mean he makes mostly like knives for chefs and house us.
But he does them all by hand.
The hammers,
the steel,
the whole deal.
And you're watching him coach and what pieces and Polish them down.
Well garlic.
So in knife story Clapton and these things are like,
you know,
25 50 grand knives,
some of these old like,
you know
real to me tich collected,
well this isn't vintage,
this is all handmade stuff,
but it's just too,
my used to have a regular job and then I think his company is called Brooklyn
cut and um,
he's goes,
started like,
you know,
it was like in a funk and he started making knives almost as a hobby and then it
became as is his job.
But as he's making these knives,
it's like you're,
you're really interested in the craftsmanship and his passion and enthusiasm.
That's so addictive.
I don't have any desire to make knives.
Yeah.
If I could kick a knife,
I cut it tomato and the knives done,
done.
I'm done.
Pretty fucking cool to see someone that's just,
you know,
he's obviously that's his passion and,
and he's putting everything into it and I think process
goes further than street smart than book smart.
So I often describe myself as a street smart guy cause I left school early
without a lot of education.
You were talking earlier on about and the path people go down where the in
school,
University College,
you know you come out when the 2123 and they've got no idea what they want to
do,
what they've got all these degrees in education and,
and then sometimes they just sort of float around.
For me it was a complete opposite but just always trying to enjoy life and find
things that you enjoy doing but the kids never give up.
You know,
it's like that guy with the knives,
you know,
turns seems to be a hobby.
Passion into a what sounds like a pretty successful business.
Came over here in 98 I didn't even have a driver's license so that's hilarious.
When you consider what you do now I want to see him drive.
He drives a little quicker.
Not that good though.
Yeah,
it's good.
Not as good as him.
He's actually,
you know,
it's funny you mentioned,
you know most of your collection is a,
you know,
the early cars and low powered,
but you know,
I left the car with him.
It rained in la,
remember like a while ago.
For like a week thanksgiving.
And you know my wife actually who made that video that you saw because she,
yeah.
Which is not as good as he as actually the one with Kermit,
you know.
And it's not one of those home videos you guys like yeah we like to do those but
that's a different one.
Then he goes a private in oil or something?
No,
not in oil.
Just in water.
You a water cooled gun.
That's right.
I said I've got to get it in there.
But yeah,
I mean you know,
we left it that well.
I said I've got to get back on a flight.
I need back story before that.
Yeah,
we'll tell them the back story.
But the point where you're trying to get at is it,
you left the car with him to try to get them addicted.
Exactly.
And this is like the hazard.
Go for the back story though.
This is the third or the fourth time.
And just watching him sort of go up in his,
in his roads,
not in,
you know,
a two,
seven,
seven or an early car.
And,
you know,
he respects the power,
but it just eases it.
And,
and like I said,
it was like a,
like you found a song on the radio that he liked,
if anyone listens to radio,
but you know,
and he's like,
I think I liked that.
And it turns up the volume a little more than it goes back and,
you know,
chops to mark tomatoes with those knives probably.
And then it goes back.
I like that song a lot actually,
and I'm going to turn it up a little more.
And he continues to cook and by the end of like,
that drive was a two hour drive.
You turned around to 11.
Yeah.
You know,
instead of having like 30% throttle or a three out of 10 on the volume knob,
you know,
was more at seven or eight.
And he's like,
yeah,
this is,
this is uh,
this,
this needs some uh,
time.
You know,
and uh,
yeah.
So I left it with them for a month.
They something that you also have to get accustomed to when you're coming from
these cars that are essentially your cars are somewhere around 200 horsepower
and then all of a sudden you're driving that things almost got four times the
amount of power.
So I'm used to sort of getting in these two 77 type calls and you just keep your
foot planted all the time.
I call him flat foot cause where pedal to the metal,
sort of my slogan gt two with almost 800 horsepower.
He,
you can't do that.
So pedal to the carpet,
gradual pedal to the metal,
you know,
to me.
So it's a lot about variety and the challenge with that car is trying to get
comfortable with it where you feel confident,
where you can push it more and more and you know,
break later,
get on the gas earlier type of thing.
And it's a challenge to build a modular and try and get the most out of that
car.
The flip side to it is,
you know,
driving around town under 4,000 Rpm,
it's pretty dosel just like any other car,
he gets real angry real quick.
But again,
it's,
it's the whole passion thing.
You know,
I'm addicted to his passion basically,
you know,
the,
from the first time I met him,
you know,
like really it was about a year ago with the blue car to the point where,
I'm crazy enough,
I guess some people think to just go,
hey man,
can I leave the car with you for a month?
You know,
some guidance got a video like that,
you know,
often the canyons.
Now you're leaving a car where it's all of one and w a modified one of one,
but essentially one of 200 ever built.
But I couldn't think of anything better.
Like I'm not going to bring,
uh,
you know,
I'm not going to bring a dolled up.
You see for me to clarify,
I've owned a lot of early nine eleven's a lot of them,
but uh,
my collections,
my own collection,
I don't build customer cars.
And I think there's a bit of this,
a miss sort of a interpretation that people think I'm a tuning sharp or a
performance shop,
building customer cars to get these emails all the time from guys wanting me to
build cars for them or can they drop their car off.
And I've had quite a few people approached me wanting to do collaborations with
other tuners.
So you know,
just to clarify,
I'm a collector and I like to get out and drive out on build customer cause I've
helped my buddies out occasionally.
So when Alex approached me with the car and just sort of left it and he gave me
the classic line,
like what I think is going to become the old time,
classic line for me,
he goes,
just treat it as if it was your own car and do whatever you want to do with he
painted it.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm done with what I call opp other people's Porsches.
You know,
for me this was just a real fun collaborations bell to put my sort of artistic
stylistic interpretation of the Sixties and seventies sport purpose era onto a
new car,
which is something that hasn't really been done.
You know,
no one's really took that 60 70 styling and put it on a new car and the Porsche
welds a little bit black and white in a sense just to sorta be real broad is
rather an air cooled guy or you're a water cooled guy,
you know,
and a generic term.
The two don't necessarily mix even though they really do all the folks in onto
what we're talking about.
Just explain the era.
She's not a Porsche Forum we're on right here.
This is just a regular podcast,
but it's essentially it was [inaudible] 94 was when nine nine three ended
production.
It was 98 that was lost.
And when that happened,
when that happened,
oh you know,
Porsche guys that were,
you know,
fanatics for you know,
30 40 years.
I started in the beginning when we came out in 1964 and was air cooled.
So we'll start there.
Start there all the way up to 98 literally people that were Porsche guys want it
to jump off a cliff because they thought it was over.
It was over because Portia announced they're going to water cooled and they were
just like,
that's the end of Porsche.
And they went to water.
Cool.
Because it was the only way
to really get more horsepower that and I think it's cheaper to pee,
you know,
in a way it's cheaper and to mass produce.
Cause they,
when they were air cooled they were making fewer cars.
Yeah.
Volume one volume.
We're not,
you know,
they introduced the ball,
you know.
Actually that's not true.
It wasn't 90 well 98 they made the last air cooled nine,
nine three but in 97 they actually introduced the Boxster and that was the first
water cooled.
So you wouldn't know about the box?
No,
I any my friend Lou clothes,
he had one.
It was an automatic,
God bless this great.
You know what's great about,
doesn't it?
The exhaust pipe look really weird in the middle like that.
It's a little weird.
I've seen one with two circles.
That's the,
that's the,
that's good.
The new one is beautiful.
It is actually.
Yeah.
New Kilowatt and you came and you know they got this thing coming out 40 full.
That's real.
It's happening.
Cayman gts are on steroids so it's like a gt three but I wouldn't go that far.
It's still,
it's still modern and all these guys,
you know,
do the shot,
works tuning and take a bite out of the Cayman.
You know what's interesting,
I'm becoming an old,
like a newer version of you,
like a older grumpy sort of new car guy.
Because for me the new cog.
Yeah.
Because the,
the golden era for me is the error of Joe's car.
Nine nine seven nine nine seven gt three for most seven.
I like the 961st Porsche
turbo in 2003 I think today that nine nine six turbo is the best bang for the
buck.
And you can put the 35 grand and really fast car.
Yeah.
But mine was a lemon.
Mine broke down like crazy and I got away from Porsche's for awhile.
I'm an NSX.
I went in for an Nsx and then I got rid of that NSX.
I got another Nsx at two and a sexist,
but then I found out about the gt three and I was reading about the road.
My car broke down five times to replace the engine.
The throttle with the throttle,
the fuel pump broke.
So I just ran out of gas.
The fuel gauge broke,
that's a clean problems.
He ran out of gas.
The fuel pump broke as shit gets broke twice.
That was a really common problem.
If you looked at it you would laugh cause you're thinking like a hundred and you
know whatever $30,000 car and it's got this plastic piece of shite basically
linking,
linking the floppy,
you know,
shifter to the cables on the transmission and that thing would break on cars
from 97 cause it's the same part in a bog standard box or to a turbo.
And Yeah we always had to make like a billet part for the early cars shift.
He made something much stronger actually a company in Arizona that that it's
like a tuning partner for me,
Eva.
They make it and um,
yeah,
it's just a little billet piece and then yeah,
you don't get,
cause you know what happens.
You get stuck.
You can't shift,
you can't go anywhere.
It's,
I got lucky.
Mine stuck in second gear.
That's a good year.
It was stuck off.
That's a good year to the Porsche dealership.
That's a good gear to be stuck in.
That car happened twice.
It's pretty stupid.
Why don't you get the GT three?
I got the GG three year before
I met you.
So was it 300 or 2010 you went hardcore math backwards.
I love the deal.
I loved it.
But then I found out about the shark works cars and I was like,
oh this motherfucker just took,
so my wife's video.
Yeah,
I saw the video and then it was the cover of excellence.
I think it was 3.9 was on it and they were talking,
the guy was just raving about the engine.
It was comparing the three plan must be your buddy,
right?
P S yeah.
Pete Stout.
That was the,
and now he's in charge of Panorama.
That's right.
So I got rid of the 2010 bought a 2007 had it sent to Alex,
never even saw it,
didn't even see the car right off the showroom floor,
sent it right to even driven
new stock and I talked to him like this motherfucker is exactly what I wanted to
hear.
Everything you're saying,
I'm like,
that's my dog in the car.
We go,
let's do it.
There it is said go crazy and crazy and I,
I loved that car.
What?
Favorite road to go drive.
I love that Angel's crest.
Crescent heart man.
I'd love to me of that.
No,
no.
I called them.
Oh you're going to say yeah.
Well we were up there yesterday at the other side of it that had a big session.
It's such a masterpiece.
When I drove it I was like,
this is like better than any ride at Disneyland or six flags and I got to the
bottom and those that when you drive a car like that on a crazy winding canyon
road,
no one anywhere near.
That's when you really understand what these cars are all relate to that God.
It was so fun.
That was sort of how I connected to the GT two,
you know,
and then just little by little eased into that car.
And then uh,
you know,
these guys had already added performance.
I just started a little bit of style and personality.
But you did a crazy,
is there a best website to look at the images of the width of the version of the
one that he created?
Basically.
Hey soul over soda grounds to cram.
So if you go to like the shark works Instagram or Magnus Walker,
right?
You could see it.
I mean you just sort of like,
depending on what relationship to it,
it's on my Instagram,
look at that guy was a Honda Teesha night guy.
Who the hell is that?
That's a sexy looking gt.
Two to tell.
It looks like I got some holes in my jeans.
It looks good when you see it in person,
it's like the blue car
and then you came and saw it and you were drinking coffee and I think I like it.
Yeah.
The 4.1,
when you see it in person,
you see the blue and the orange [inaudible] that's where you go and you can hear
it if you play it off that other one.
There's a video of a Matt Farah driving by I think hearing that fit.
Yeah,
I think so.
You can hear that.
That's just my Instagram.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
The folks that it looks pretty fast to come around that term.
That's,
that's pretty cheeky,
right?
Have it British flag and Jack upside down.
People are digging that vast.
She's then that's what these grids,
Union Jack on,
chairman,
chairman cost also.
You did the thing with the seat inserts.
We took,
uh,
my wife and I took a UK tour right before Christmas.
We did an event with Porsche in London and then went to see my mom in Sheffield
and then went up to see my sister who lives in Aberdeen,
Scotland.
Bird theme.
So a,
but dean,
we've got some iron blue.
Yes.
So,
you know,
I'm a big fan of messing up interiors in cars,
but Porsche had been putting plat interiors or tighten interiors in these cars
since the 70s and though it's hard,
you know what you guys call it Thomson Tartan,
you know,
and they make a lot of that in Scotland,
you know them.
Then we'll William Wallace dudes with the kilts in the spars and the Haggis.
So anyway,
long story,
short it up and show their Willie's or there are that thing.
I was just there for the top and fabric,
but I managed to find this time that,
uh,
is almost the same colors that are on the car,
so I couldn't resist,
just put in the inserts into the seat just to give it a little bit more
character on the inside as well.
I mean,
when you open it,
you just go,
does it make it drive any better?
But it just sort of looks like he's got a little bit more a style and
personality.
The,
I bow down to you guys on this.
I just do that.
That's your,
you're into it.
I like solid colors.
I don't like plat interiors,
but honestly that car has a lot more character in a very unique,
weird way.
Now that you've got a lot of person,
I wouldn't have done it.
But in and with the gold wheels,
yeah,
it does work.
It really does help those three color combos,
you know,
and just sort of Trifecta or I call it,
and like I say it's an acquired taste,
but it's sort of a late sixties early seventies race inspired library
interpreted onto a new car,
which is,
I don't think you'll see another car like that out there.
And you see the privateer teams,
you know from the seventies eighties that to me is when I see that car going
down,
you know,
as opposed to just being like a stealthy white nine 11 with a sort of big wing
on it.
That to me is the glory days of Porsche nine 11 came out in 64 the one Lamont in
1970 so that first 10 years,
you know,
Paul should you start a winning everything in the nine 11 nine 17 and that's
just like the iconic sort of era.
The beginning of everything has become this automotive legend that has gone on
for 50 years and there's only two other cars that have been in production as
long as the nine 11 the corvette,
which 10 years before I've got a 65 well,
you know what I'm talking about then and uh,
everyone's favorite.
The Mustang and I'm always forward that people don't do more Mustang Porsche
sort of comparisons because to me I've,
around the same time,
it came out the same time I owned a 65 Mustang gt three 50 our replica and the
Mustang owner on the pusher on it and me are very similar in the sense that both
of them love to customize the cars.
You know,
you see a lot of upgraded mustangs.
I mean just look at all the Parnelli Jones,
the Shelby's a bus three o two is you know,
these factory conversions on the mustangs.
It's just never ending the night 11 in a sense.
He's sort of a similar thing and I think the owner,
an enthusiast of the two cars share that common bond of the cars are easy to
sort of upgrade for a performance point of view.
Personalize them from an aesthetic point of view.
And they've both been in continuous production for 50 years and the both icons.
You look at Ford and I think you identify forward with the Mustang.
You look at Ken Block and what he just did with his Jim Karna seven that thing
is ridiculous monster.
And I was holding
that video.
Well that is blocked Chicana seven I never had a Mustang,
but like in England,
if you,
if you were thinking of an iconic forward,
it was probably like a Ford Edge Se.
No,
well that too.
no.
It's a Ford escort XR three I,
it was the most stolen car he grew up in.
I think.
Here's the,
here's the video.
First of all,
how beautiful is la look at night like that?
That is,
I was fortunate enough to be a couple of hundred yards away from some of the
scenes he's running on the,
you know,
the guys that you work with on the wheels the same or 1552 wheel nine Mustang.
Is that what it is?
What year is it?
Oh,
well truth be told,
he's sort of a completely purpose built car,
but the real Kido is 800 horsepower and four wheel drive.
It's in sound believable and I think what they did for 40 in a way,
ways bringing a whole new uh,
client,
uh,
Fan into chem blocks world.
And also the Ford will throw this Mustang,
which to me just looks like Darth Vader meets Mad Max on steroids.
That is looking Mustang we've ever seen in my life.
It's a 65 look on the fact that the try was a notch a notch back as opposed to a
fastback.
Notchback and why does fender flares,
he's just a monster.
Look at this.
Unbelievable.
He's going to spin the wheels.
Oh yeah.
Four wheel.
It's got it hooked up to a chain.
All wheel drive,
a Mustang spinning all four wheels on the sound.
You know,
I'm not hearing that sound,
but he's just in
see cadence.
There you go.
Unbelievable.
It won't go.
Only all wheel drive performance Mustang ever built.
What's
the benefit of having a car like this all wheel drive though,
Howard down better,
right?
Yeah,
but that's it,
right?
It's going to change the hand where it makes more smoke.
Even spoken all for this guy is a fucking mad man.
Yeah.
He was driving to that video that he did with his Subaru where he's spinning
around.
It's different objects that on top gear,
right.
The control that he has in this thing.
I thought that San Francisco,
Jim Karna five was the best until I saw this man.
Salix is going on still that big,
but this one,
he's in downtown La.
Go and sideways around every corner in the craziest fucking Mustang that's ever
been built.
My mother in law sent me this video.
Have you seen this?
It's like,
yes,
you're right about mustangs though in that Mustang's might be the most
customized.
Every car without a doubt,
I would say.
I mean,
what else has been around in production for 50 years and they're also one of the
most radical cars as far as what you can buy,
the most radical,
which you could buy straight from the factory.
And they were the first to go completely hogwild that gt 500 with 668 horsepower
mean,
what the fuck is that a road?
I mean,
that is bananas,
bananas car to have a live rear axle in 2014 the new one,
have you seen the new gt three 50?
They've gone the other way.
They've lowered the horsepower down to 500.
They've lightened up the car like that giant carbon brakes.
And apparently with this new independent suspension,
it's a motherfucker as
far as its handling,
it's supposed to see,
see,
honestly,
I would actually take a slightly less horsepower,
but lighter.
I don't like that Ford Gt.
Aw.
That was one of my old time favorite cards as a kid growing up.
The,
uh,
the gen three 50 is the new Mustang.
That's a Ford Gt.
Yeah.
The Ford Gt has a beautiful car prices on those ones.
Paul and Chris doesn't modern version of it and modern one is just insane.
Nobody ever drivers like the 300,000.
Well I had a friend who had,
when he said it was dog shit,
he drove them.
It wasn't,
I was,
it was a time when I was thinking of getting one.
It was the,
the Gulf livery one obviously cause I like weird colors and you know it was
around one 80 at the time.
So it was like the best time to buy it.
And now I see they're like 400 grand but nobody ever drives those cars.
So yeah,
that's the great thing.
About nine 11 was in Porsche's get shit out of him.
You see a lot of high mileage pull.
She don't see a lot of high mileage for old lamp.
Exactly.
Anything like that.
You know one other thing about that,
what you just saw.
So manual transmission is standard.
That's all you can see.
How great is that?
Speed manual is the sole transmission.
So l e n s o DOL bow down to that one of my,
you like the sticker on it like the gt two,
the antitheft sticker.
The madness.
Yeah.
I love that Dan came up with that.
I think it's felt well done roast that Porsche is not making manuals.
It's really disappointed and that the worst thing is you know,
well that came and she too full.
It's coming manual.
That's going to ruffle a lot of feathers because guys are going to go like you,
well nine nine one gt three guys.
You've got to go,
how come I can't get a manual in nine nine one gt three is ripped the soul out
of that car.
The out of the GT three program when they,
you know,
said it's PDK only,
I get that they have to compete with you know,
the Nissan Gtr or the [inaudible] and all these,
all these cars that are basically,
you know,
automatic.
Can you just push a button and it does everything for you?
They go,
well actually you do have to still push them playing numbers.
They're all children.
And even on Norberg ring,
they can't compete unless I agreed.
But they tell us about the journey.
I think you know the interaction and you know the control.
You put it into the charm in the leg,
you know,
you're just like your full night's sleep.
The nine nine one gt three is honestly the first gt three ever that I've been
sort of Borden,
you know,
it's a gt three r being bored and I'm like pushing buttons cause I see,
oh it's got some new buttons.
What does this do?
Well instead of like actually going,
wow,
I'm really engaged.
Don't get me wrong,
it's a great car for a first time Porsche by our spas.
But that's who's buying them usually and not the hardcore gt three guys who
don't really know how to drive a manual.
I have a friend who's wealthy who doesn't know how to drive a manual.
And I go,
listen,
I go right a car,
I go rent a car for it.
No he doesn't.
But he's thinking about getting my little dog fight.
I go rent,
rent a car,
rent it for the weekend and beat the shit out of it.
Learned how to drive.
You can learn how to drive it in 10 minutes.
It's not hard.
It's like eh,
that's shit.
Look into exactly how power ain't going to be.
And I say covers all the sensors.
That to me is a great thing about driving.
I think ultimately it doesn't matter what car you drive,
but what matters is being engaged and involved in that experience,
which covers sight,
sound,
feel,
touch,
you know,
two hands and two feet in the canyons.
Once you get bored,
just,
just all you would do is put,
cause you probably not even push buttons anymore,
but you just push the gas and you're going around and it's like,
okay now what?
My arms not doing anything.
My legs not doing anything.
I'm not getting that feedback.
It's my daughter.
I have three is a PDK car.
Yeah.
Essential.
It does.
Great.
I,
it's my traffic car traffic chart.
It's great because it,
he loves Graham.
Yeah.
Constantly.
I'm the opposite.
I lived 200 yards from where I work.
So for me,
80% of my driving,
walking pure pleasure.
Do you have like a regular car that you drive or do you come,
well hold on,
hold on.
I Walk to work.
So I got the garage full of cars.
I have my wife Karen,
her car,
what I call the wife's car is a regular car.
Four door car.
The BMW.
I am so much shit for that.
You know it's funny.
The BMW.
No,
no,
but I mean it's,
it's,
you know,
the funny thing is when bespoke four door and they look at me and go,
the puzzle Lug,
they go on you that push.
You got to go.
Yeah.
They go,
what are you doing driving a BMW?
I go,
it's my wife's car still great car.
Three,
three five I BMW,
you know,
sort of for driving it.
No,
come on.
I have a two thousand twelve billion out of 10 the iPhone.
But you know what I really liked?
I liked the generation before mine.
The,
you know,
the one with 333 horsepower,
the [inaudible] 46 yes.
That's a beautiful car,
man.
So a lot of people may track
sort of track cars out of those.
And then even the eat 36 that's like probably the most common sort of,
you know,
like get into know tracking other than them Yada.
That's,
you know,
eat 36 m three is when those common truck on silver I've seen.
So I always loved the 2002 Tii and the 3.0 Batmobile going older,
old school,
go back to old school,
seven eight always go back.
Why is that?
Why,
why are you a solo things my age,
my era,
you know,
I'm 48 so I grew up,
born in 67 grew up in the 70s well thanks.
You know,
so as a kid,
those are those informative years.
Alex is a little bit younger so I think his point of reference is eighties my
point of reference,
his seventies and I remember watching motor racing on TV on grand stand on a
Saturday watching a sports program in England on the BBC two channels I think.
No,
no.
We had three from 1982 they introduced free channels and then I think it was 82
or 80,
BBC two and ITV,
they went with,
now we're going to unveil channel four.
And literally the entire country stopped as if it was a royal wedding.
Right.
And the very first program was this thing called countdown,
right.
Which was like a game show where,
you know,
they would have like their pick letters and you'd go,
I'd like a vowel please,
or I'd like a consonant please.
And they put it up and you'd,
you'd sort of have to fill
in the blanks,
you know,
and they'd have celebrities and stuff and they'd go,
okay,
well,
you know,
give me an a,
give me a,
you know,
sorry,
give me a letter.
And you know,
you'd make a word out of it.
And it was like,
that was the first program to launch the channel forward.
And you're like,
well,
I don't remember that.
I remember a old grey whistle test,
top of the pops.
They were,
the music shows top of the pops up
every Thursday,
top of the pops.
And then,
uh,
what was channel four's music show in the 80s?
Oh,
that was a,
it was with Paula Yates,
Marin.
Bob Geldof it,
um,
I think to the,
to that was it,
this is pre MTV,
so it actually is going back.
It was pretty trendy.
They had some really good bands on it,
you know,
sort of a cool era of music.
You know,
my thing growing up was I'm from Sheffield,
so Sheffield was sort of,
I portray at grim northern steel town,
but it was also a great music town.
You know,
Joe Cocker,
who recently passed away from us from Sheffield died recently a couple of weeks
ago.
But when I was a teenager,
you know,
late seventies,
early eighties,
Sheffield was known for its new wave bands,
human league having 17 ABC cabaret Voltaire.
But the flip side through it was def Leppard,
Saxon heavy metal music.
So Sheffield's always had a great musical vibe.
I guess the current Pinup band from Sheffield,
Arctic monkeys,
which are sort of those guys,
she had all these northern environment towns,
you know,
Manchester,
Sheffield,
Leeds,
Liverpool.
I think the breed creativity,
cause you know,
people are just looking for a way out,
something different.
You know,
back then in the 70s,
it was pretty depressed.
Steel mills closing down coal mines closing down.
So miners for exit,
well we'll talk about that later.
Not your favorite subject.
So there was a,
uh,
there was a movie I saw recently called pride,
you know,
you like English sort of humor,
black humor movies.
Um,
and this is gonna sound weird.
It's like full Monty on steroids.
It's,
it's called pride should look it up.
Um,
small sort of British movie.
We'll probably win some awards came out this year,
but it's about the coal mining strike in the 80s,
which I remember growing up,
you know,
the coal miners practically chancre down when the miners went on strike.
Exactly.
Everyone was on strike and there was police brutality towards the miners that
were striking.
But there was also police brutality to gays and let,
well not lesbians,
but gays mostly at the time.
Cause lesbian gets brutal with lesbians.
Well you don't mess with,
you don't mess with that.
So in London and,
and you know,
they were,
they were activists and they were thinking,
well,
nobody's taking us seriously,
but we have something in common with these miners in the middle of Wales.
Wales is this thread.
Do you know what that is?
Yeah,
I know you said it before.
It's,
it's the,
uh,
I'll let you say since you are the dirty minded one,
but yeah,
you've got about a black hole,
black hole.
I know,
I know.
How dare you.
But they are,
you know,
being beaten on a daily basis and you know,
base,
you're just just penalized for being gay.
And they're like,
well,
we have a lot of in common with these coal miners right now what we're going to
do is we're going to form this coalition called gays and Lesbians for minors,
you know,
coalition and we're going to raise money for them.
And so what happened is,
you know,
they would raise money since all these miners were out of jobs and striking,
on the,
on the streets.
So you can imagine in,
you know,
the 70s and sorry,
an eighties,
the early eighties,
you know,
gay people on the street going,
hey,
would you like to donate to the miners of Wales for gays and lesbians,
you know,
were gays and lesbians,
would you like to donate?
And they're kind of looks and things where like that's,
that's an interesting thing.
Yeah,
it's really cool.
So then,
you know,
they,
they get all this money and they end up actually getting a lot of money for
these minors and they go visit them in Wales.
They get in a,
in a bang boss basically and go visit them.
Um,
and when they get there,
you know,
you have to fear,
you have to realize that,
you know,
these are coal miners.
There's probably,
there's probably homosexuality there underneath,
but what are you trying to say
that they go digging?
Yeah.
Guests for coal,
fossil fuel things.
It's about doing the fossils,
thinking you're doing it wrong.
I haven't done it,
but yeah.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
I've read books about it.
I just shake their head and go,
yeah,
this is not the right tech technique.
Well,
the different than the Ewan Mcgregor coal mining brassed off movie rights.
It is about the brass band.
Yes.
But they get there and there's this hundred and five year old,
you know,
grandma that's,
pouring tea for all the miners at their club and working man's club.
And she's,
and she's just like,
you know,
whatever the guy's name is,
who is in charge of them.
She goes,
your gaze or here,
you know,
and it's like the whole place just stand still
and you know,
they're bringing money for them and they form a bond.
They actually kind of turn them around.
It's happy go lucky.
But then not to put a damper on it,
but then,
you know,
the main guy gets his was one of the,
he's the second person with the uh,
to contract aids in a,
in the UK said he died.
Sorry.
But the other,
sorry,
the f
and the other guy does,
sorry.
Well,
the other guy leaves.
The other guy does live here,
that Russia recently ban transgender people from driving from drive.
How would that impede anyone from driving properly?
Well,
you got to not dress like a woman or dress like a man.
If you're a woman,
could you?
Oh,
you mean,
I don't know.
I think Trans transgender transsexual trends,
trends,
anything,
any transmission.
PDK transmission.
Yes.
I like they have bouncing around male transmission.
That doesn't make any sense.
If they're holding a stick,
Russian is um,
they're,
they're so archaic with their,
their views on homosexuality or kicking him.
Dave,
Dave like decided to just literally ban.
There's documentaries on that too.
Yeah.
They'd go head hunting for them.
Like,
you know,
really crazy.
It's a,
that country is falling apart right before our eyes and coincidentally it
doesn't make a good sports car.
Russia.
Yeah.
No.
Well they know what they did.
They remember that the Russia,
they did,
they bought the,
the worst British car company you could possibly buy.
They remember that Russian guy.
He was like a 20 year old kid,
billionaire.
He bought TVR Trevor out of black.
Yeah,
he bought and that's not a good car company.
I mean they,
I like the styling.
The styling's good.
Just don't drive it.
Just don't cut it.
Windshield falls off the boat load of power.
Remember I remember that,
uh,
top gear episode where,
you know,
he's testing like,
one of those weird looking TVRS with the paint,
you know,
from the mid,
early two thousands and uh,
you know,
the,
the windshield wiper actually just like flies off.
I mean,
it's a factory car.
It just flies off going 120 miles an hour.
Yes.
This is how crazy rush is.
They've,
they've lumped it all in with rational ideas.
Like you shouldn't be allowed to drive.
Your blind shouldn't be allowed to drive if you have like probably a good idea.
Right?
Yeah.
And then along with that,
they,
they listed the desire to live and be accepted as a member of the opposite sex
and people who wear clothes of the opposite sex in order to experience temporary
membership of the opposite sex.
Those people,
what was the truck drivers must not have sex disorders.
So what was in,
can you have sex in a car in Russia though?
I hope so.
Yeah.
Going on since the communist era for sure.
But the crazy part is that,
um,
you know,
they had their first f one race there.
Right.
And sort of like coming to Texas,
you know,
a black guy,
Lewis Hamilton wins the first race.
You know,
it's,
they don't see many black people in Russia.
I mean it's a very sort of white place.
It's,
it's actually quite racist.
I know because,
um,
I have Russian blood in me.
Unfortunately.
That's the racist party.
You No,
no,
not at all.
Not at all.
Actually,
I was born and raised in London,
very cosmopolitan.
I have many,
many green,
yellow,
you know,
black,
he's a lot of United colors of Benetton.
Really?
Oh,
there we go.
That's right.
I remember that.
I remember those.
I always think of them as American apparel,
like CD,
basement,
wood paneling.
And that's how I look at it.
But she,
she's,
she,
she got kicked out of a memo saying that you say factory episode you did down at
the American apparel.
A facility down down,
down there.
Alim downtown.
Yeah.
Speaking of which,
our t shirts I made by them free month by the same guys that make it for Tesla.
So it's all here.
The main guy was supposed to be very weird.
Eccentric of shady.
Creepy,
creepy isn't he?
Like there's all these articles about them does seem to a trial.
Just pay the bill.
We just pay the bills for it.
I don't know.
I'm ready to kick him out of the company and somehow now they bought his way
back in and they a huge pretty quick,
you know,
still is everywhere and you know,
yeah.
Well it's all over the windows in their underwear and wood panel.
It's actually about that company is,
I'm on the labels,
you know,
we can,
we can specify what we want.
So like you know that blue,
that bright blue thing,
you know,
it's not that one cause that's a demo.
But we're going to have labels that say,
you know,
smell no where until it smells.
Yeah,
no,
this was made by,
you know,
people over the age of 12 you know,
that didn't,
you know,
earn 1 cent a month.
You know,
it wasn't exploited,
you know.
Well that's a whole big thing.
Surely verticals done in La real wages.
So it right there on,
yeah.
Well I've been to their fans,
no shark fins in it.
There are regularly like a million square feet of production down there.
It's unbelievable.
Well it's the,
the front though,
cause I'd be really disappointed she made in Honduras,
made a factory.
DTLS I've walked down through there.
I've actually,
what,
when we're filming there,
we actually walked through their factory.
Yeah.
But this,
what happened,
this is going back to the geeky thing.
Sorry.
But when I was still talking about England and four channel talking about
whatever the fuck no,
but when,
so 1998,
you know,
I'm out of a universe,
97 actually,
I'm out of a university and I'm doing this website thing and I'm going to,
you know what cs is right now.
So it used to be called on the Big Bang theory for Geeks or that that's come a
big bang theory.
There's wine.
Yes.
Wang Chung.
Um,
I was invited to go and speak in Taipei at the,
you know,
like the Chinese version of it.
Um,
and you know,
I went there and result,
you know,
you got to visit all these motherboard companies in Taiwan.
Um,
and uh,
you're like,
oh,
this is where I get my,
you know,
a Seuss motherboard and I overclock it.
And they're like,
oh,
thank you for mentioning us and all this stuff.
Yeah,
he knows,
he knows.
Sorry,
computer and a,
my printer the other day and there's all these rather nice factories in Taiwan,
but you're sorta like,
can look in there and going,
this isn't made in Taiwan.
There's no actually doing anything.
All they're doing is taking these things and boxing them and there's like dust
that thick on the,
uh,
you know,
on the equipment and on the tables and you start to realize actually what
they're doing is they're making it in China for way,
way less,
you know?
Sorry to break that,
but it was disappointing.
Oh,
so they make them in China and they box it up.
Yeah.
But it looks like they're made.
And so I was just saying,
I hope it's not like that with those tee shirts because I'm very,
I wanted to go with a company that was local,
keep it sort of,
you know,
in California.
I don't care about paying more for it,
but I feel at local,
well,
I feel bad for,
you know,
12 year old kids or whatever in Honduras or wherever it is,
earning a dollar a month,
you know,
to work 20 hours a day to make a t shirt that I can sell for,
whatever,
30 bucks and it doesn't feel good.
Yeah.
That whole thing that he really doesn't,
something happened in America where they started moving almost all of our
factories and all of our overseas.
Yeah.
All,
I mean,
most of the cars.
So I mean,
look at what happened to Detroit.
Detroit was essentially gutted.
I mean,
Detroit's [inaudible] cars,
Detroit,
I mean that it's like a ghost.
You
couldn't have picked a better one.
You know,
I flew to New York,
took a Trailways bus from New York to Detroit,
worked at a summer camp with kids.
That was how I got to America in 1986.
And then spent some time in Detroit,
which looks great from Windsor.
If you go across the,
uh,
the,
say you didn't have your driver's license.
I didn't drive in England,
Iowa.
You know,
as a kid growing up,
nobody had co we couldn't afford one.
First of all,
that was weak at and either she spent everything on my step one score on the bus
for five p.
But you know,
it's,
uh,
you can go back now and be it,
get an old age pension of free passes almost.
You know,
what does that AAP,
once you get to 40 50 I'm almost as close.
I will say though,
just for the record,
the first car I ever bought,
I bought it here in Nla,
passed my driver's test in La I think in 1987 when I was 20 at the Santa Monica
Dmv in in 1977 Toyota Corolla two TC that I paid 200 bucks for it cause I was
the very first guy on second car was a Sipe turbo,
900 SPG and the third one was a nine 11 is what do you guys feel as as
Englishman living in America?
Top gear,
the number one television show.
So I all time when it comes to cars,
but Jeremy Clarkson is pretty adamant about being like Antique Porsche.
Yeah,
he's,
he's known to be had about Porsches and that's okay.
He actually,
there's this episode I believe it's,
they love caravans on top gear.
It's before the new sort of format.
I think it was either late nineties or early 2000 you should look this up,
but if you look at that video,
it's on youtube by now he takes what now is probably a six.
I was probably a 60 $70,000 nine 11 it was like a,
you know 73 yeah,
John a piano on it.
He tries to destroy it.
Hits walls where they're going.
Yeah.
That must've been the first generation that show.
Initially it was cancer was canned because Tiffany dome was on the phone.
That's what I grew up watching and I think you mentioned this with Chris Harris,
how Tiffany Dell drove with him and stuff and yeah,
that's what I grew up watching nation and from what I can gather,
she liked it better than,
I mean it's really spectacular now with all the explosions and all the
silliness,
but it's sort of like jackass for car guys.
Tiffany Dellschau fifth gear.
I did that show and that seems to be a bit more of a serious,
well all of them can drive to and what's her name?
Vicky who used to be on there.
He is right there with this car.
Oh Dude,
your man is on point.
Look at that.
I wouldn't have found it.
Let me look at it.
And he's got,
he doesn't even have a smashed that car though.
I mean that is a fucking beautiful government is then these cars were under 10
grand all day long now.
Isn't that amazing?
It's amazing.
Our prices doubled and then tripled.
Like what is a like a 1972 like really nine 11 hours left this in this well
prepared wall.
Two to 300 grand.
That's include a 73 Rs.
He drives a fucking piano on it.
Don't do it Jeremy.
Yep.
That's the final on camera.
Ah Fuck Man.
No,
but he does way worse.
He goes into like walls.
He just,
he cripples the thing and it just keeps on going.
That's the joke about it really.
But it's kind of fucked up to that car.
Takes it to beating.
They are rock solid walnut man.
Yeah,
they are.
Well,
okay.
I mean,
who would've thought,
you know,
we're,
we're racing around in the,
in the,
in the canyons in a 71 it's just set up right.
You know?
Yeah.
To 77 well,
44 years old now.
Yeah.
That thing's know aging very well.
Those cars are amazing.
I feel bad just watching that.
Actually.
It doesn't do well.
It is crazy though.
I'd rather watch those other videos with that you found last time of like,
boom.
He know people making love to orangutans or,
or no,
no,
no.
It was,
no,
I think,
it wasn't that.
It was,
you were saying a horse was banging a dude.
That was true.
That was the one that you were,
you were really high on that one last time.
Hey,
with the language.
Sorry.
No,
no,
no.
I'm shocked.
Pulse raced,
disturbed commodity on.
No,
that's a good job.
Said like the movie Avatar.
I enjoyed that high on that
actually.
And it was in your standup too.
You said the noise that that guy makes,
we'll stay with you for the entire life.
Well,
it will entirely for watched it.
I didn't watch you make the noise is as good as watching it.
You made the noise.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
I don't,
I don't want to.
It was,
it was coal mining in somewhere in London,
Kentucky,
yourself thing.
Back to my original point.
Did you ever want to get Jeremy Clarkson,
one of your four point ones?
I mean I want that guy to drive that.
Not Him,
not him,
but actually Richard Hammond,
but he likes portion.
He had a gt three Rs,
a green one like ours.
I really wanted him to drive ours because I think he,
he understand it.
Clarkson,
first of all,
he wouldn't fit in the seat because he's a bit of a Chubby tubby guy.
Matt Farah fits in.
How the fuck could Clarkston not fit in?
That's true.
Actually.
He just said on the way,
however that when we were driving his car,
when Matt Frost side on it,
it's developed and new creeks that might want,
it wasn't there before
Craig,
that's on the passenger side and it wasn't there yet as good solid two 50 if not
higher.
The weight distribution was a little bit different with him in the,
yeah,
he could,
he could go on a little bit of a diet.
It'd be better.
Nice guy though.
He's super [inaudible] 77 so that was good.
I think he had fun in the GT two as well.
But it was raving about your two 77 raving about the way it handles about,
I think it surprised.
Yeah,
no I,
Matt,
Matt sort of got it towards the end of the day too.
Cause at first he was like,
Oh holy shit,
holy shit.
This thing's like,
you know,
and then just ease in,
just ease in and the more he spent more time you spend with that gt to such as a
month pretty quick.
Because before we got to the canyon,
I was in the passenger seat when he was driving and we did do the one full seven
well he's also one four seven kilometers.
No,
it was miles per hours was four seven who's professional driver on a closed
coolest,
I mean come on.
Full disclaimer here.
Matt Farah is awesome.
One of those guys that really loves cars.
When you're around him,
it's the same sort of infectious sort of vendors or flowers.
Yeah.
When he's driving those cars in those videos,
I mean that's how I became friends with him is watching his videos and then
reaching out to him.
Like his videos are fun.
Like he's enjoying driving those cars.
It's not like some sort of an antiseptic review of the sings.
He's excited about it.
Passionate.
He's got a collection of cars himself.
Delorean,
that's the car.
That's the car model,
right?
We punk nick three chiller.
I knew it was going everywhere and that Delorean,
so got a lot of style.
Exactly.
You know a guy that shows up in a Delorean that's,
that's a,
that's a good dude.
He's here to party.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I saw one the other day in Hollywood,
so Laurie,
Matt.
Yeah.
I looked to see if it was Matt drive was just some weird nerd,
some guy.
I mean,
they're cool to drive now.
It's like you said,
a photo.
I run into him at the La auto show not long ago.
The opening day or did you stop going to be parking in the same spot underground
at the convention center,
but he pulled into the handicap zone.
An Impartner put.
He pulled into the,
opened up the door and I took a photo and of course I had to put it up online.
Of course,
within like three minutes is all this of,
why is that asshole parking in the handicap zone in the Delorean it,
you know,
it didn't take long for that to to get punchy.
Mentally handicapped for only a Delorean.
That's what it,
I think we're all challenged here and a little bit challenge ball.
Unempathic excited in a very illogical way.
Let's,
let's,
let's put it that way.
It makes sense.
It's a mouthful.
So I want to get Jeremy Clarkson in one of your cars,
man.
Hey Jeremy,
if you're out there,
I'm sure he's listening right now.
Come on,
I'll show you.
He doesn't even know what the Internet is.
Seriously.
He does not.
I'm sure he's,
he calls it the interweb.
He's any,
any,
you know what he calls?
You know what he calls a Prius?
A Prius.
You know what he calls an Ipod?
Ipod.
Well,
you guys said it's aluminum wrong too.
No tomato color code.
What's up with Aloe minium belt belt?
I don't know.
It's just fell the aluminum.
We handle it differently over there and you just pronounce it differently.
Calorie spelled differently.
See?
Oh,
aw.
Don't want to speak English anymore then go ahead and speak Spanish.
No,
we're speaking American speaking to Moran.
I used speaking.
We run the world now.
It's a different thing now.
China does he say so,
but we have all the bombs.
Essentially.
If the shit hits the fan,
American ticks.
China has some bombs on this nuclear wasteland.
That is the world we all go to war.
Yeah.
It's just like Frankie goes to Hollywood,
right?
Yeah.
Go to the wall.
Two tribes go.
Guests can't deny American.
When you already moved over here and said
the grass is greener way of the same in American citizen,
I'll have you hollow.
You know how I became an American citizen?
You the only in this country.
How I was working way too hard mean I had a green card.
Yeah,
I,
I shook hands with them and we went across the border 98 all right.
See you man.
I'm Super Newbie.
Yeah,
no.
So I did all the process.
I hadn't what was known as an o one visa,
which is like a special thing.
Pre nine 11
it was kind of easy to get an la for people that were like Internet celebrities.
Well,
Internet celebrities,
dude,
you should it.
You should've seen my groupies mad.
Can we go on to the shock is extreme size.
I don't know.
Sharkey extreme until you don't do that.
Don't do that.
Yeah.
But when,
when you went to these things,
you know,
there was actually one time that I had that a woman actually showed up,
so it was like really cool group.
He,
one time I had a woman,
but most of them are guys.
Anyways,
back to that.
Yeah,
no,
you watched the Big Bang theory,
right?
That's sort of how I imagined.
No,
but when I,
when I got here at the o one visa then,
then I got a green card.
You know,
I got married to my girlfriend who was a game developer and um,
you know,
I started another company after retiring,
which was shark works out of a hobby again.
And uh,
you know,
sort of a few years into that I'm like,
okay,
I have to get the second green card,
which I think is three years later.
So they,
they make the appointment and I lose the card.
Right.
You lose it the way I think,
the way I lose it is by bringing it back to them,
seeing how he loses,
at least my lunch,
good green card story when need done.
So I take it,
you know,
I take the green card back to them,
the original one,
and then I'm supposed to come back in three months and pick up the second
version of the green card.
I don't get,
I don't get to the appointment on time because you know,
I'm supposed to make an appointment within six to nine months and I'm so busy
with Shork works that I don't,
so I come there,
the officer there,
you know,
eventually is like,
hmm,
well we're never going to find it.
I mean you're here like a year late,
so you could either start this process again or do you want to just become an
American citizen?
Literally.
I'm not kidding you.
And I was like,
okay,
test right there on that.
So I did like,
uh,
no,
not,
not in the spot.
I had to come back and do a history test.
And at the time he talk about the Mustang.
No.
Oh No,
no,
no.
That's it.
What was this?
This uh,
John Adams thing was on HBO.
Fucking useful.
Sam Adam's brother.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
that's the last,
the one that's [inaudible] stories,
right?
Yeah,
man.
no mom,
I picked up on that and then,
you know,
my education finally came in handy because,
we did,
we did a lot of history and stuff and actually,
you know,
the Brits did kind of ruled the,
pretend you're ruled the waves back then,
you know,
we call nice everything including the wing of a Gett.
Um,
but yeah,
so that's how,
that's how I got it.
And so I filled out,
it's not cool to come in for a visa and they said,
look,
just because some believable,
just become a fucking citizen.
You speak English,
you look kind of weird.
You have never said that to me.
It's a really my green card story.
I'll make it really short.
You know I'm on a green card.
I've been here 28 years.
Recent couple of years back,
I go to England,
leave,
leave La,
no problem getting into England,
no problem.
10 days later I'm ready to go back to La and they go,
okay,
we need to see a green card.
I even looked at it and about two years,
well tuned out,
it had expired.
Oh yeah.
What's the big deal?
It's sorta like it expired two weeks before you not homeland security's Klein on
a suspended grandfather.
Karen's all upset because we were like,
how long is this going to take your work?
You may have to stay or a week or two and go to the embassy and blah,
blah,
blah.
Anyway,
long story short,
we got a 24 hour extension just to fly back into the states.
Got Sorta hammered when I came into lax because of course they thought this was
some Mickey mouse 24 hour extension.
But long story short,
don't let your green card expire in 2015 it's really hard to become a US
citizen.
Right?
It's a much harder for a white English guy that has or had a posh English
accent.
It's probably not as hard as it is for people of other ethnicities.
I mean for a guy with a northern accent and I'm talking with a different skin
color,
a turbine,
you know,
if you're all white that,
have you heard about the turban outlaw thing?
We're doing the Turpin,
our urban outlaw terminology,
Chub,
little ritual.
Boy Turban doesn't start in a corner shop.
Does it?
The band corner shop?
No,
it does not start.
And have you ever thought about doing something like with singers doing but
doing it with like the,
the actual classic shape nine nine you know,
1970s night late 1960s car and like producing them bill?
No.
You know,
I think I touched on that earlier on about I don't build customer.
I know you don't,
but coming down what a demand there would be demand there for sure.
But you know,
then it goes for me from being a hobby and a passion to a job in a business
which means responsibilities.
He's like if you come to me and say hey I love you kaba his all of a sudden it's
not my car,
it's your interpretation of my car.
It might have some tweet on it and you know,
might be pumped up and you know it's all of a sudden it's got your personality,
which is fine.
But then I'm sort of under the pressure I believe to make your happy to build
the car to your expectations,
your timeline,
your deadline.
So I don't really have any interest in turning that side over to becoming like a
production line.
Even though I know if I built let's say three or five cars a year,
I could probably sell them cause I've had no problem selling college.
You know,
through the press.
I've got people,
I get all these emails.
If you ever want to sell that call,
let me know type of thing.
It's interesting though with so many collectors out there,
so many people who customize cars and do the,
you've sort of somehow or another just by just your own infectious passion,
enthusiasm,
you've risen to the top.
You probably short about the long hair and the beard.
I think,
you know,
it's a little bit of that,
that stuff anyway,
I don't know,
time phony.
I think it was luck and timing,
you know,
um,
last year was the 50th anniversary of the nine 11 so you could not escape
hearing about Porsche in the nine 11 50th anniversary issues.
And I think from a story point of view,
the builds that I would doing were quite interesting.
But I also think not being your typical Porsche looking guy,
because truth be told there is a stereotype,
especially in la of doctor,
lawyer,
Beverly Hills guy driving around,
never taken his car to the canyons,
you know,
just more of a status symbol.
So I was a complete opposite of that.
So I think from a story point of view,
why I got a lot of sort of momentum was couple of things.
Timing,
not looking like a typical Porsche guy.
And also the cars that I build instantly recognizable is nine 11 but just
slightly tweaked.
You know,
I said little details,
I think separate my beliefs from the countless other people building cars and
the one common thread between the fashion,
the clothing and the property and the filming that we do is just put in our own
little style on it,
which became personality.
And for me,
I never set out to say,
okay,
here's the 1973 RSR that left the factory,
the Porsche factory in everyone that replicates that car,
just duplicate exactly what the factory,
what I want to make this point too,
because a lot of people are gonna ask me,
how did this happen?
And you know,
he hasn't made a single cent from like what happened is,
you know,
we sat down by the fireplace how money and had a baby,
which is a gt to outlaw Gtt when you two together.
Yeah.
I wasn't sure what it was throwing them out of there either actually.
Oh,
just check your rear end later.
Um,
for coal,
coal miner's daughter Co oh Jeez,
that's a good film.
Was going downhill,
is gone down.
No,
but there wasn't a sent me,
actually the only thing he's gotten out of getting out of me was,
uh,
one 18th a scale white Gtt,
which I just happened to send him the day I got the car.
And the funny story is that,
um,
Dan who was here last time,
him and I,
the first day we got that Jeetu we're like,
well,
it's not as pretty as the a or flashy or crazy as that blue and orange car.
What the hell,
what we need to do is make a sketch of his two 77 car.
So we,
you know,
we used Photoshop or he did because I suck at it.
And um,
he did like a five minute job of a,
uh,
of attribute car to the two 77 and emailed it to him and you know,
I texted him and he's like,
how's the horsepower coming?
You know,
basically that's just English subtle way of saying,
you know,
don't,
don't quit your day job,
start making calls,
go fast.
And perhaps the moral to that story.
And I sorta kept needling,
needling and needling and he had to live with it.
And you know,
he just,
I don't know.
Right.
Cause he got passionate about the car.
So he did.
Listening evolved organically.
I think I touched on in the past,
people have asked me to collaborate on,
you know,
some of the people's builds and for me I had to be connected to the car,
uh,
and I think when they left the car with me for as long as I wanted really raise
only one time for a long time in la,
but I finally connected with the car and then it just made sense to put my
personality on that carcass.
For me,
this is not about money.
I'm not making money off this collaboration.
It was just a fun project that,
wow,
this is great.
I've got this awesome car that I can keep for a little bit.
Handsy,
Opp,
other portraits,
baby,
you can do whatever I want to do.
And I,
you know,
it was just,
for me,
it was really exciting to put my sort of interpretation on a new car.
You know,
I'm sort of moving forward in the Porsche years often talk about variety and
wanting to experience more of what Porsche has got to offer.
So for me,
my original goal was having one of each year from 64 through 73 which covered
short wheelbase and long wheelbase cars.
Now you need one from 2007 my new goal now is to have one of every generation.
There's seven generations,
of course,
you know,
through the g series align to the nine nine s nine nine (396) 499-6997,
nine,
nine one.
So I want to experience everything that Porsche has to offer in the nine 11
range.
So far I've covered sort of,
I've driven all those calls,
but I've never owned them.
Well,
let me ask you about this then.
You,
you,
you really love those old cars.
And one of the things you love about those old cars is the tactile field.
When you know you're dealing with a car that weighs 2000 plus pounds and such a
light car,
you feel the road,
no installation,
no power steering you,
you literally feel the pebbles that you're driving over.
When you get to like nine nine,
six and nine nine seven you're going to get like a more muted feel [inaudible]
experience compared to the hill you get to the gt three and the gt three sorta
removes some of that insulation,
better car to do it on then a car that you only produce 200 nobody understands.
When you say new car,
it is a newer era car,
but it's actually a 2008 car.
We,
you're talking about your car that yeah,
the Gt to put it this way,
right?
Walter Raul,
we,
you know,
he's the world's greatest brow x rally drive Easter,
right?
You know,
drive group B rally cars that were like death traps.
And when,
um,
you know,
he did,
mid seven minutes in a Carrera gt and the exact same time in a stock version of
that gt two.
So the gt
to these guys have got Scott 200 horse power more than the career GT and British
flags on it.
Easy a car to drive.
But is it an,
is it unmanageable?
I mean when you get to that kind of power,
the way he drives it actually he manages you wear,
you wear it well.
Is there a point of diminishing returns?
We have too much power in a car and you're spending so much time trying to
figure out,
trying to not kill yourself down.
Yeah,
you obviously don't need 775 will say too much power is never enough.
I'm the lessees mall type of guy,
but I got to say horsepower is addictive.
You know,
I had that mopar background driving the superbeets and those things were
addictive in a straight line.
The GT two,
there's no question that's a scary car and it's got 775 horsepower.
But that's sort of part of the challenge of can you man up and sort of conquer
that power.
You know?
And that's one of those things that unless you,
you know,
I've got,
you want to speak really talented,
I think he got to grow into that.
So to me that's the challenge of trying to get the most out of that car.
You know,
and I've sort of been lucky through these guys to belt drive various variations
of the gt three.
You know I've driven in stock form,
I've driven the three nine have driven the full point and I've driven that gt
two this year I got to drive a lot of my dream cars and nine 11 or uh,
drove us 74 hour saw but I drove three of Porsche's iconic super hyper cars and
I'm five,
nine the Carrera gt and the nine 18 and they all offer,
I keep going back to variety cause they all do the same thing differently.
And that's sort of what's great about the gt two.
It does the same thing but it just delivers it in a different form engine.
You know on the challenge there is truth be told that car is done by 7,000 rpm.
You're on the limit or you're bouncing off the limit or 6,800 rpm and he's done
step into two 77 that's got a quarter of the horsepower.
That thing will rev or over 8,000 step into the GT.
Three 3.9 or 4.1 those things go to,
well 86 88 and nine
kind of just talking about numbers here,
but what my point is is like there's two different schools of thought in two
different philosophies that you're dealing with.
You're dealing with in one school of thought,
the cars that you are famous for,
which are these really lightweight cars that are very tactile and there's some
sort of a strange character to those cars.
Like even when solid urban outlaw video,
when you get into that silver car and you rev it and you're,
you're looking at the gauges,
it has a feel to it that you just do not get from a modern,
well,
there is a,
there is,
I mean you've admitted this to,
there is like some level of connection between visit Dnas that still there
unquestionably.
You know,
it's a little heavier.
It's a little more margin out of the cup holder,
but it's still got that.
That's why I said the golden era before 2007 to 2011 those gt cars,
they have their old manual,
they still have that link to the real nine 11 I,
that's why that car has gone up in value so much.
You know all the gt cars because people that know and there aren't many of them
unfortunately,
and that liked to drive.
They get it and they've had all the cars or they want older cars,
you know,
or the parents have had older cars and they drive these new ones and it's like,
you know what?
It's okay.
It does all that stuff a little more comfortably and has nav and all that Shit,
but it's still a nine 11 I think the gt three up to what you've got,
the nine nine seven is the connection to what I've got from the sixties and
seventies yours.
It's like a baby gt.
Three cars,
sat,
throttle response,
the light nurse,
the way it feels,
the road,
the weight turns in his back to that.
I keep talking about it,
the five senses,
the connection,
the sight,
the sound,
the feel,
the smell,
the gt three has that,
you know,
uh,
and that's what's great about those because I've yet to all one,
I'm trying to get a nine,
nine six gt three.
So I think that's the most bang for the buck.
I mean,
truth be told,
I've been collecting these early nine 11th for over 20 years when you could find
them in crate,
you know,
auto trader and I bought two 77 at the Pomona swap me in 1999 and it just,
it's a second pusher I ever owned and it's evolved into us become,
I think my,
the car that I'm most connected with in all my memorable moments in everything
you talk about that tactile feel and the connection and sort of what I think to
me it got across in urban outlaw.
The documentary is so common thread that everyone relates to,
you've always got your favorite car that you go back to an I described that
being like my old favorite pair of beat up jeans or your old shoes because you
just comfortable in it.
There's no surprises.
And it's funny,
you know you spoke highly about Matt Raven about the car.
You know,
he got comfortable in that car within half a mile where you know,
he was pushing that car.
So the limits are not that high where yeah,
the car is fast but it's not gt too fast where you know you're not going to get
way over your head really quickly.
I think that's the difference.
And that to me is the challenge of driving these early causes.
Yeah,
they're antiquated by today's standards,
but it's every time you get an I talk about driving for me is freedom because I
don't come you,
I walk to work.
So 80% of our drivers are pure pleasure.
It's like you're working out in the gym.
No two experiences are the same,
I don't think.
But these are rewarding satisfaction.
I assume.
I don't work out.
But to me,
I often say people,
like some people like to go to gyms to work out.
I like to get in the car and drive.
That's my physical and mental workout is behind the seat of that car because
nothing else matters when the,
either you're not thinking about what you might be pissed off about or you know,
something that's sort of bugging you want to get behind that wheel.
It is the sort of almost out of battery sensory type of expression of man and
machine on the Oprah with those simplest
lightweight cars.
That's where you're getting this experience.
And I think that's one of the things that people miss when they talk,
oh,
I don't care about cars.
Cars get me there,
or everybody gets wrapped up in cars.
I think what they're dealing with is the difference between like a modern
commuting car and what you're driving,
which is essentially like a ride.
You're,
you're in a ride.
You know what I said is it's sort of like,
I like surfing.
I've had seven concussions so I can't do it anymore.
But You got a concussion from surfing.
I got one from surfing and six from soccer.
Football.
Oh,
and sorry.
One from being a passenger in a car.
One time us from Ralph,
right.
He was semi pro football back in the day.
No,
no,
just,
just basically this,
just call it public schoolboy footballer.
Then how about that?
Okay.
That sounds sexier.
So David Beckham shouldn't be worried about you.
Oh,
no,
no.
I was too left.
I was too lazy.
No,
no,
no.
I alright with the,
no,
I was left footed.
But um,
yeah,
it's sort of like surfing where it's not for everybody.
It's,
it doesn't make sense.
I mean,
in northern California,
you go out,
it's 50 degrees in the water.
There are some sharks actually.
Um,
and it's gnarly and the surfers are not friendly at all.
They're very localized and they hate you and you can't open your mouth if you
don't live there.
I just watched that film,
like,
it's like that surfers,
man.
Let me tell you,
Santa Cruz,
there's where I go.
You know,
it's not the friendly city.
I mean you would think they're all,
you know,
lit all the time and everything,
but they're not friendly.
It's like,
no,
this is my way fest and get the fuck out of the way.
Fest Keith was stolen movie this settler
lost boys.
Oh,
Yeah.
That's cool.
Santa Cruz,
Santa Cruz.
Right.
I don't really know.
I don't know.
Location was like a main point.
And then I think it was the vampires.
Vampires what the big deal.
You missed the point dude.
Missed the point.
But go ahead.
Right.
I know when I go surf,
I mean there's better ways.
There's better things to do with your time that are less risky probably.
Um,
cause it is kind of risky to do that.
So driving a crazy weird lower production car that's doesn't make a lot of
sense.
It's challenging.
But then,
you know,
why do people,
I mean not to make it sound glamorous,
but you know,
why do people bungee jump or why did they,
you know,
I want to do something that's sort of challenging and takes time and it's
rewarding.
You know,
you get one out of 10 shifts.
Correct.
Or you know,
the senses,
it's a sensory studies chat.
It's a challenge.
Right.
I mean,
you know,
like with your MMA stuff,
I mean you probably started as a white belt,
you know,
back in nine,
everybody does.
Right.
But let's really start,
right?
Yeah.
Well exactly.
But it takes
time and it's challenging and you know,
you beat up your body and,
and it feels good when you get there.
So,
you know,
the blue car beat the shit out of us in terms of the development,
the costs,
the,
the setbacks,
you know,
it didn't make any sense to do that.
You know,
it should have just focused on something that,
you know,
it was a high volume,
high production car,
like,
uh,
I dunno,
like a Prius and made it get better gas mileage,
you know,
then,
then I'd be,
you know,
driving the world's most pimped out Prius probably.
But that's not what I wanted to do.
I want to do something that's,
you know,
feels good and it's challenging and you know,
work with these kids,
you're surrounded by Weirdos like him.
That's what I should go a long way.
You know,
I'm for me,
you know the best things in life and never really
literally like I said the,
Oh okay.
There is one thing he's getting out of it.
Okay.
So other than the one 18th scale model,
I said,
dude,
I can not look at your smashed iPhone five anymore.
You're really,
really good at all these pictures and everything.
I'm buying you an iPhone six
I'm helping you.
Awkward.
That's what he's getting.
So I got kicked out.
I resisted,
resisted,
resisted up until 18 months ago.
I was still Motorola flip razor phone.
And that to me was cool cause everyone's here,
whether iPhone,
giving it this side on the other.
I'm like,
what the fuck is that about?
And then finally my Motorola Razor had died.
I literally,
I had no choice other than a real sort of throw away crap burner phone or pause.
The only have three buttons,
something like that.
Yeah,
exactly.
It was that,
oh an iPhone five.
So I got the iPhone.
I remember I got it before Amelia island last year.
So that Amelia island,
nothing is march,
so barely out the iPhone two years and that sort of how my life's changed in two
years was never on Facebook,
wasn't on Instagram.
Still.
He's still on Twitter.
It's little.
I'm trying to set him up with that.
It's you gotten
Magnus Walker probably going to go,
you know what we can do,
we can do,
we can do sharpness walker.
He goes,
what?
We can shock a shark despite this.
Wilken nine 11 my friend Ari went back to the flip phone.
He goes,
no,
Ari Shaffir standup comedian.
He went back to the in his iPhone and went to a flip phone,
went off the days,
all of his social media stuff,
either on a computer or not.
He doesn't check his Twitter on his phone.
His,
he's like,
I was getting too wrapped up in like,
I would be talking to someone and I to this guy.
I wonder if anybody sleep last night on like literally my iPhone hit my forehead
three times and I finally gave up because I was like,
what the fuck am I going to post another concussion?
You know,
I'm like,
I'm looking at,
I don't think it's spelled correctly and it's probably like,
you know,
a bunch of weird wingding character brings me back to what I was gonna say is
like there's,
there's,
there's something about iPhones that drag people in,
right?
There's something about like being able to look at videos and you're,
you're interacting with your phone.
Yeah.
The interaction that you get with those old cars,
the field that you get,
the addiction that you get to get in those things is very different than the new
cars and is there,
and I wanted to ask you this because you're the expert on it.
Those older cars,
they're like a point where it crosses this line and it's not the same experience
anymore.
And was there like a sweet spot in the production of cars?
Where's,
where there a spot where all the technological advances and all the advances is
suspension.
Although they may allow you to get around a racetrack a little bit quicker,
especially with like PDK transmissions with dual clutch is working at the same
time.
They do allow you to get places faster.
But is it,
is it missing all the stuff that gets people excited about cars?
I mean,
cause I know that driving an automatic car is fun.
It is satisfying.
But I also know it's not as satisfying as shifting your own gears as the field
that you're going to get from a car like yours.
And I think that that's something that's missing.
I think ultimately moving forward the manual may become a lost art because you
look at kids growing up today that don't know how to drive manual cars.
So the point of reference is completely different.
You know,
I,
most of us here I think learn driving a manual car and everything he said is
perfectly true.
That ac interaction between man and machine,
which gets you down the road differently in a manual than what it does in a new
car and a PD care automatic and uh,
asked to try to nail down a real answer to what is that sweet spot.
I don't really know what the answer is to that question.
You know,
I've driven almost every Porsche are out there and you know,
I've driven the new turbos.
I,
I've driven the new,
uh,
came in,
which is a phenomenal car.
I've driven than nine,
nine one in manual and PDK and the new manuals and not the same as your manuals.
You know,
they've got,
this is hot to heel and toe.
The way the pedals are set up,
especially if you've got ceramic breaks where he spleen heel toe to people don't
know what the fuck you're talking about is sort of another thing when a
downshift and you know,
you want to be basically on the brake and Britain the throttle at the same time
doing it with one foot.
So covering two pedals with one foot and the early cars,
it's really easy to sort of modulate the brake and the gas pedal.
You know,
I'm often put little blocks of wood on the gas pedal to bring it further up.
So when you're all the way down on the brake,
you can just sort of squeeze it,
break with your right toe and roll over to the throttle to blip it.
So you matching the engine rest when you downshifting that essentially as water
for the heel and toe aids,
you know it's a smoother transition between the gears.
So as you're shifting gears,
you're revving the engine at the same time to match.
You know when you're going to do the lightweight flywheel that allows the,
the,
the wrap.
Some of the early college don't have that.
But what these guys are doing is super throttle responsive,
lightweight,
flywheels like hey components.
It just makes it like you know,
and a new one you'll nine nine one it's a little bit different cause you got
those ceramic breaks of travel on the brake pedal.
Let's say you're coming down to these crest highway in fourth gear.
You want to make a right or left hand turn.
He got to go down,
let's say third or second,
got to go down one or two gears and you're all the way hard on the brakes.
The travel different between the brake pedal and the throttle on those new cars
is almost too big to rollover in heel and toe.
So you know,
they've sort of come around that with that sport.
Plus mode where automatically blips the throttle for years.
What I wanted to ask too,
when I first got in the car,
you know,
I can get it where I my first almost on a 45 degree angle,
nice sideways where I can roll off,
uh,
you know,
kick my foot on the brake but still modulate the throttle at the same time.
So what I ended up doing was double blipping I'd blip and then almost the exact
same time the computer would automatically blip the throttle to match the revs
assuming that Porsche thought most people don't know how to heal and toe.
Now the rev matching the
on new cars.
I think the Nissan three 70 was one of the first cars to do it.
Yeah.
There's actually the newest Porsche,
which is sort of known as the,
we're sorry,
addition Porsche to for gt three guys of what they did is,
as I said,
the nine one one gt three came out only in PDK.
The gts now has a proper manual transmission,
not like the fake manual transmission.
With the nine,
nine one?
Well it was actually that you could get a manual,
a seven speed,
um,
nine,
nine one if you really,
really tried.
But it was essentially just a PDK box.
That's all it was with a fricking gear shift there.
And then what's the difference?
Well I think Chris Harris explained it.
Oh,
the new ones.
A real Christian Hindu explain it.
Yeah.
To get Chris and he's got it.
Yeah,
I know.
Well he like he was saying,
you know like you can,
you can go into like seventh gear and it's all like,
like this.
And is this just,
it's such an odd gear on those by now and once.
Cause when are you ever in seventh grade if you're driving to Vegas because,
cause it was a PDK transmission,
they have to get,
the new one exists.
I mean they have a six speed manual transmission.
That's a new transmission.
The new one is the seven speed is a new one.
That's what I'm speeding sport mode,
uh,
yet does no,
no it doesn't.
It doesn't go like [inaudible] speed
if it's so annoying,
but they have to use it because it's a PDK transmission.
It's got seven years.
Those new cars.
When do you get an a nine,
nine one and it's PD.
Can you just driving around town before you even up 50 miles an hour.
You were in sixth or seventh year for folks focusing on know what the fuck are
we talking about?
[inaudible] it's a German word.
Partial Double Club.
Dong Dong,
Ding Dong.
It's a crazy long word,
but what it stands for is two clutches.
And what it means is that there's one clutch that grabs the gear.
The second clutch already has the second gear grabs you.
So the change between gears,
which we first and second gear is literally instantaneous.
It's,
it's so fast.
Say your,
your brain can barely perceive it.
So as you're driving,
when you're driving a manual car,
like man,
you let off the gas,
he hit the clutch,
Wang,
you put it in the next gear.
This one's like,
man,
it's just so quickly that there's no way you'd have bill to do it on your own.
That's the fault of the Nissan Gtr.
By the way.
The Nissan GTR being so fast and so technologically and never says that calls
solace though,
right?
Well actually what nobody says really?
Well,
yeah.
W which is really annoying because some of my customers bought them.
They,
they fell for the hype,
and don't get me wrong,
it's amazing technological piece of blocky something.
But what it does is it takes a lot of weight.
That's a really,
really heavy car.
So a lot of journalists will take it a few hot laps and it's like,
man,
look at this lap times.
Look at the lap times.
But the guys actually ended up buying them and going on the weekend.
They would have to,
you know,
like change trends,
change the fluids they were,
the breaks would be cooked after like one session and one session.
Meaning,
you know,
20,
30 minutes.
Not much.
The Porsche is,
you just bang on them,
you know,
change them.
You change breaks and stuff.
Yeah.
Eventually they have ceramic breaks.
They have them too.
They can just have that option.
Um,
yeah.
Even Corvettes have him,
you know.
Sorry,
not even car.
I'm just saying,
you know,
cars are a lot less coal vet.
Let's be honest.
That's a lot of bad ass.
Oh,
you were telling me that you had driven around the corvette,
z o or the a Camaro Zl one.
And you were saying how addictive that was.
I was who shows me at the Zr one.
But you got a chance to drive the Camaro for a while,
didn't you?
Oh,
there's the 28 you're talking to you about before.
You didn't drive the Zl one.
No.
God Damn Way.
Most of the other guy with the beard.
If you've never driven one of those Camaro's no,
no.
It wasn't yesterday.
Super B,
but no,
never Camaro.
You've never driven one than never loaned you mail for awhile.
No.
God,
why do I feel like it was you?
You were talking about the visited by Bib,
by Volvo.
I got visited by Ben,
believe it or not,
the guy from Butte Gatti but yeah,
no other than than portion.
No one's ever alone because I'm just,
or shark works.
Yeah.
All shot.
Well,
you know,
I'm just so thrilled up Porsche loans because,
but no,
not me.
Yeah,
no.
But the nine nine one gts to touch on that is the,
is the latest one that they've just released and it does have a proper manual
gearbox in it.
Not the pseudo PDA one.
The scenes like the in between car between the g three and the regular night and
they're like,
okay,
you can order it in manual.
We don't care about performance numbers.
Um,
you know,
it's an MNA car.
It's sort of like a manual gt three if you would.
It's the way,
sorry.
It is actually aspirate edge.
That's true.
Naturally aspirated dude.
What the fuck you're talking about?
It's an MNA car.
Basically.
It doesn't have the hairdryers or a blower or any forced induction booze.
All it is,
is vacuum and a good car.
This GTS,
a lot of journalists are raving about it.
I think Chris Harris was about to go drive it after your show or he was back
from it.
I'm not sure.
But um,
Ralph you drove.
It didn't you,
uh,
or they took it up to you and you didn't like the automatic Blippar he didn't
like that.
No one can hear you.
So yeah,
unfortunately she want to get on the microphone but basically,
sorry.
Yeah,
but um,
yeah,
sorry dude.
Um,
if you,
if you want a manual modern nine nine one platform,
that's the car to buy right now at this very time.
I don't want one,
but that's if you want.
And what are they going to do with this gt four?
What's the specs?
Is it going to be a fast car?
The Cayman Gt four.
It's funny you talk to people at Porsche and they won't tell you anything about
it.
You know,
say it's essentially a Cayman gts are on steroids with suppose a gt three s
performance right in the mid engined already great handling Cayman Package.
Well,
that's the thing about the Cayman for people who aren't aware,
nine eleven's our rear engine car and there's certain inherent flaws in having
all the weight in the back of the car and you move it bullet to the middle for
the Cayman.
They came in,
which is a mid engine car is better balanced,
but they have purposely,
Porsche has an underpowered that car in order to keep the nine 11 of the top of
the food chain.
So we sort of being handicapped because as we know,
the nine eleven's top dog been around for 50 years.
Essentially the Cayman,
uh,
handling capabilities are really,
really high.
I mean,
you didn't get an a Cayman,
you know,
and go fast.
Really,
really quick push alone.
Big,
uh,
came in last year for a week.
And my favorite Goto road is Angeles crest highway.
And then I had two of them,
uh,
manual MPD.
Kay.
And I'm pretty comfortable in the Angeles crest highway.
I drive it all the time.
And two 77,
I was amazed at how much quicker it was or I was in the Cayman with less effort.
So back to the original question,
you know,
the reward,
the payoff versus the effort put in,
um,
quicker in the Cayman.
But the drive is not quite as rewarding.
Right.
Cause I'm not quite as involved with it.
We had a,
we had the first year it came out,
we built,
we built the first year it came and asked as a,
as a shop car and it,
and then uh,
you know,
it got tracked a lot and went up through the canyons and I'll say,
it's an o six came and asked and we added a bunch of more power,
lightweight flywheel,
better suspension,
better brakes,
tried to make,
you know,
better seats.
Tried to make it like a canyon carver.
And it was easier to drive fast.
And it was also like anyone could get in it cause it was just really well
balanced and drive it fast.
But it was missing,
you know,
the special engine,
the whole connection,
you know,
the steering wasn't quite the same.
The feel wasn't the same.
I mean,
it's really nice to have that engine over the back because it's always like
tugging at you and you've got to think about it.
Whereas when you're in the Cayman,
you can just drive like an idiot.
But isn't that a crazy thing to say?
It's good to have a flaw because you have to think about that flaw in counter,
that philosophy,
moral law that they've worked for that until you look at it,
you know you can rotate a lot quicker.
Yeah.
So and have,
and you can put more power down better too.
Right?
Because you not traction in the wheels.
I mean that's why nine 11 down,
you weren't that gt two,
well yeah,
800 horsepower he's spending but call number two 77 with a quarter of that,
that power just Biden into the ground.
Yeah.
And you can come out,
you get as much better corner speed xx
you,
which is why I'm still a believer in a sense of less is more because you've got
to put more and it's a more real,
I keep going back to reward.
That was what I was going to get to.
Are you,
are you more comfortable?
Do you enjoy the older cars better or do you enjoy like a like a 4.1 gt three
when you're getting in the 4.1 you're doing any nine 11 beyond my 1979 nine 11
sc yet I've owned over 59 eleven's.
I bought my first one 23 years ago.
But you've driven the other carbon them.
I do see in my future a space in the garage for a newer Porsche nine 11 probably
some form of nine nine six or nine nine seven gt three but I also just said
earlier on,
I want to get one of every generation.
I also recently bought a nine 24 let's talk about Porsche's.
Unloved caused nine 24 I bought a 1989 24 front engine turbo.
That was Porsche's first production front engine water called Turbo.
So my new goal is to have one of each of the three let's call them ugly
duckling,
Porsches nine two four nine four four a nine 28 nine 28 is a weird one,
Huh?
Yeah,
I mean,
you know what I mean?
It's just back to variety.
It's like I've been so focused on early,
early Porsches and I've driven,
you know 40 almost 50 of my cars have been early portion,
so I've sort of covered that base.
You know I've covered,
I've got one of the first year in 1964 and I've driven the,
the tail and buck and let's call it the iconic 73 Rs Carrera.
And they all sort of drive in a sense,
same but different is how I describe it.
So you know,
now I'm back to variety.
You know,
walk is more variety than a nine 24 940400920 eight this is disgusting cars,
unbelievable cars at all.
My nine 24 terabyte cost me 4,500 bucks.
It's unbelievable.
I'll tell,
I swear to God,
I took a couple of posts out there.
It's silver with charcoal,
has got the black and white,
what Porsche calls pasture or checkerboard interior.
And the funny parts of that story is it took about a day before,
I didn't even know the nine 24 form existed,
but a post and a thread developed on the nine 24 forum.
Someone sent me a link to it and the title was watch nine 24 prices go up.
Look who just bought one and those this whole like rambling thread about why
would I have bought a nine 24 I'm a nine 11 guy but lots of bang for the buck
and back to variety there.
Also very well balanced.
I have a friend who races them,
loves (920) 920-4944 spec series is phenomenally successful.
Just like the box the series and people email me all the time sitting on it
falls into a few categories obviously people like in the cars,
but my favorite sort of category of emails that I receive is from non Porsche
people that have maybe seen urban outlaw maybe followed my bills and all of a
sudden of being turned around from being Porsche haters into all of a sudden
looking at Porsche or a little bit differently.
Predominantly the early cars and these are guys that are looking to get into a
Porsche for the first time.
I wanted to pull up,
pull up this video,
what we talked about before,
the show Jack Olsen's nine 11 verses 1970 291119702911 versus a gt nine nine one
gt three and a Jack Olson is a writer in Hollywood who is a really fascinating
character.
I'm going to get him on the podcast too.
We talked about it and uh,
he as essentially had this lifelong,
there's a video.
Uh,
Jamie,
there's a,
um,
I can email it to you if you want me to do want me to email too.
Okay.
I believe you actually I was a a Po,
I met Jack over 12 years ago when he was first developed and not current.
It's gone through several phases and I remember giving him a call number two,
seven seven.
Ironically at Acu when I first got it and Jack Carlson was looking for an AC
compressor and actually gave him my compressor that I think it's in that car,
but cool guy and has really fine tune and develop that car.
Spent a lot of time at willow springs.
I think what you're getting at here,
there's pretty much every person you mentioned here with a Porsche is a wacky
son of a bitch.
Yeah.
We're all passionate
about this.
Dealing with the co no,
this is not a,
yeah.
Okay.
This is it.
Nine,
nine one shitty driving both cause no,
no.
They have a professional driver.
And what's interesting is that his car,
which is in 1972 car only has 272 horsepower.
It's very light.
It's around 2100 pounds.
And the modern car,
which is 475 horsepower PDK transmission to the automatic transmission,
the whole deal,
all the technological innovation,
all the suspension and traction control and a professional driver and Olsen is
still quicker.
Who's driving both kinds?
I don't know.
Jack's driving his car,
which is the 1972 car.
Okay.
But what's interesting to me is Olsen is obsessed with is one track with this
one car and tweaking everything,
constantly trying to shave seconds off of his car,
trying to hit the perfect line every time.
And in doing so,
he's able to drive faster around willow springs,
which is one of the fastest race tracks in America,
this road in the West.
And he's able to drive faster with his 1972 lightweight low horsepower car than
the most modern,
most spectacular version of the nine nine one gt three.
That is a lot of power though,
for that car.
I mean they,
they never came with that kind of power.
Well,
he's got a three six but it's still only 272 horse boy.
I know,
but they kept the wheels,
right?
Well,
it's a nine nine three stock edge.
That's,
think about it.
What did it come with stock,
right?
That was about it.
Probably 180 oh,
you mean the original 72 if you said to be one 30 if it was at one 36 30 yeah.
Well,
he's definitely added more horsepower,
but it's still,
no in 1997 technology,
I mean the,
at the height of whatever he's got,
it's 1997 technology along with some tweaks.
He's got some very custom wheels.
He's got Fukes centers with like,
I think he uses like a corvette middle.
Like he,
the,
the the wheel is the,
all his tires and wheels or customer.
I got a question for you then.
So of the two guys in the car,
right,
I don't even care who wins.
I know who wins,
but when they come in,
who do you think was having more fun?
Jack,
exactly.
You see what?
And you asked the pro driver,
I bet you if he drove the other one and even if he was slower,
he'd say it was more fun in the other car.
Well also Jack's having more fun in the corners.
Like he's keeping up in the corner.
The other guy is catching him on the straights.
I mean that's where it is.
Just raw horsepower.
It's straight line traction.
I mean he could probably have a similar time in like a,
you know,
a modern chapter one 20 wall.
I don't remember.
I don't remember what the numbers are but I remember that Jax was quicker but
that's just kind of it.
He was coming around turn nine if you watched the video.
It's really interesting because Jack narrates it and talks about the differences
between the two cars.
He knows his way around willow.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well that's also part of the rub is that one 26 so he,
you know,
look at that age.
So you know your car,
uh,
to the GT three Rs with three nine.
So I had a pro driver court Wagner,
like a,
the video you saw with the two green cars.
Yes.
So that day he was in the one 20 fours and that was on shitty tires.
So just letting you know.
Yeah.
I think a real test that is to have a pro driver drive the same cards cause we
don't have the gun.
I know Jack's got thousands of laps at willow.
We don't know who the other guy is.
Yes.
I think you put some on let,
let's say like a Pat Long,
you know I was driving with Pantene last week.
The guy that you put those guys in the car and see that small of a true test I
think.
Yeah,
same guy driving both calls on the track.
It's still,
it shows that you know like your car is not even your car,
which is for four years older than the new generation nine nine one gt three
it's not slower.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
No,
it's just still having more fun.
It's different.
I think it's all about the driver though.
Cause you know we were up in Angeles Cressey of the day.
I'm driving to 77 and you were with James in the gt three 3.9 yes,
that's right.
And
it's all about the driver.
I think the behind the car is what I'm trying to say.
The what,
what,
what Jack showing here is that these lightweight cars have distinct advantages.
They have this show Pantages and cornering,
handling everything.
My question is,
isn't,
isn't that also what you're getting?
Like this tactile response and feel from is the fact that these cars are so
light.
So there's just tremendous benefit in having a lightweight,
super nimble like the Lotus Elise Chapman.
So you know,
mantra,
why doesn't Porsche develop ideas?
Safety?
You know,
they talked about it though.
I remember there was supposed to be that collaborative effort with VW few years
ago.
Keep this thing as close to a collaborative effort of like a mid engine.
It was only going to have 200 horsepower and it was going to be about 2,500
pounds.
Okay.
It's not as light,
but that's light.
It's still pretty light.
Yeah.
And it would have been a fun sort of Elise ask kind of effort,
but no.
Instead they decided to,
you know,
release another Panamera and other Cayenne.
And when you get to the case,
which is a very lightweight car for,
for modern standards,
it's about 3000 pounds for the GTS.
Right.
Is it about somewhere where it'll be?
It'll be around there.
Yeah.
That's pretty light,
right?
Yeah.
I mean
things have just got obviously heavier and bulkier and more sort of bloated.
Yeah.
The not necessarily faster though.
No,
I still think I keep going back to it.
Less is more,
but I think those,
those times have gone when it comes to new cause push is not going to start
making a 2,500 pound nine 11.
I've never gone down ever.
Well why not?
Because it's just,
they,
they get sued because someone would die in an accident.
And Amy airbags can't you put an air bag in it.
I mean,
how much they weigh a lot when you have eight of them.
Oh,
I see.
It would have to have modern standards should be,
there's several safety standards were not ones of what sort of killed everything
I've had.
I've had a 90,
uh,
1979,
11 t with a 3.0 in it,
uh,
you know,
cams or mismatched cams.
But nevermind.
Um,
and I've had a,
you know,
79,
nine 30.
So,
you know,
I've,
I've owned those cars too.
Um,
I've sold them at the absolute worst time now that we're timing.
When I do,
when I,
I see them now and they're worth way too much.
But um,
but I've driven them enough to and,
and older cars,
you know,
cause everyone at shark works,
everyone at shark works has had,
you know,
either a nine,
12 like the absolute base base,
you know,
oldest model,
um,
or an,
you know,
James has had a phenomenal amount of old rusty cars.
Um,
cause they weren't galvanized back then,
but it's a white Guy James.
Right.
But really he's a quiet going on these,
these light that scientists that's going to create something and yeah.
Yeah.
And then you're going to like explode when you hit the gas
ship.
Point being they enjoy the enjoy,
we enjoy it.
But the reason you and jihadism
cosmo about more,
but it's like,
I like sharks.
There's a lot of different,
sorry man.
I like sharks as a lot of different species.
You know,
I like some more than others maybe,
but I like sharks.
I like nine 11 and there's still a connection there,
you know,
for me driving,
a nine oh you know,
my 1979 11 t or my,
you know,
my speedster replica,
three 56,
you know,
it was nice and I,
there's,
there's still something there that connects all the way up to the GT three.
You know,
and I,
I do get that the modern cars are losing and the fact that you can have one of
them,
I mean,
he's best known collector of air cool cars and you know,
he pushes the button,
you know,
to his garage and he's got,
two water cooled cars in there.
I mean,
that says something,
right?
But water cooled cars you have in your garage
cars,
car,
they're in there,
but you're letting him borrow them.
He's not buying them.
I've got a leaky roof and water is leaking in a carriage is a job,
but you're not,
uh,
you're,
you're trying to infect him.
Not with,
not with coal.
Mine met Alex,
I was already,
you know,
working towards water cooled,
but my heart and soul is air cooled.
You know I'm going to one water to water cooled cars just for variety.
Do you like the sound of the air cooled cars better?
This is sort of a raspy quality though.
Agonist soak Tim through the cubs or the Mfi.
It's just a different visceral sensoril feel that the new,
cause they don't deliver the same way.
Is there an issue with the cars in traffic like with [inaudible] 77 and traffic
pretty easy to drive around.
It depends on the Syrian issue.
Like if you were driving to the airport and you got stuck on the four or five in
summer,
well two 77 is unbelievable.
Even on the race track it never gets above two 10 but when you're on traffic
like stuck bumper to bumper,
it's not,
it doesn't overheat.
The turbo is run hall.
The early turbos run hot,
but my oily air cooled cause never get above two 10 to 20 the Sammy my turbo,
my 76 turbo and I'm driving to my buddy Marty's who's a raw score and received
or I'm on the one oh one it's a hundred degrees that you know,
that gauge is,
you know,
crawl in to 40 just because she sat in traffic.
So the early turbos run hot,
the early sorta a two liter,
two folds in.
I'm running no issues.
Now.
Do you take that car places like if you go to the movies we take it somewhere
and just park it to shut off.
No problem.
You know,
it's a very valuable car though to just leave parked.
I never think of it that way.
You know,
to me the sum of the parts of two 77 there's nothing.
If you,
if I give you the bill sheet on what that,
what that car is,
there's nothing really special about it.
But I think the uniqueness of the car is he's developed his own personality.
You know,
it's not like I ever raced at Daytona,
but you know,
I used to do 40 50 track days here in that car with a pusher on a club between
2002 and 2007 but there's no real significant race history to the car.
But I think the connection people have to,
the car really is a real simple theme and message.
He's like,
just follow you dreams.
You know?
That's,
that was my dream car.
It still is my dream car.
But it evolved.
It wasn't like this wasn't like I went out and wrote a check and just got a new
car delivered.
That call was,
you know,
our board of at Pomona swap meet.
It wasn't fled.
I talk about customizing Porsche's straight away,
change the motor in that car and you know,
just made it look more like a 73 Rs Carrera.
And that's the great thing about these early Porsche's is the really easy to
customize.
You know,
we've touched on a little bit,
a lot of things are interchangeable.
You can take a two liter motor out and put a three six and if you want,
that's what Jack Olson did.
Take out these two four and put in a three,
six.
So last,
the great thing about these nine eleven's in the get driven,
the develop personality to 70 sevens got personalities.
Jack 72 black beauty car thing is what he calls it is also pretty unique and got
personality.
You know,
the two causes a similar yet different.
That's ultimately the great thing about early Porsche's is the developed
character and soul over time to slight Patina.
You know,
some people like shiny cars,
I always say dirt,
don't slow you down.
I'm not worried about rock chips and scratches because to me those are memorable
moments that are earned over time and the ruined by getting out there.
Dry Meat,
cover meat.
You never meet a uh,
a guy at a Porsche event or sorry,
at a cars and coffee event and he proudly proclaims,
you know,
I've got 305 miles on my,
2007 gt three quite the opposite.
You know Ralph has like 68,000 on his,
on his 3.9 gt three bill,
sorry,
driven 70 more now.
Yeah.
They're built to be driven.
And that's how you get connected with the car.
You don't get connected by it by leaving it in the guero show.
There's some,
there's some nice sort of curves on it and it looks cool,
but every time you drive it,
stuff happens.
You know,
if you're,
if you're driving that particular car,
I think ultimately it's not necessarily about getting familiar to be the
quickest,
you know,
it's more about enjoying that journey and just sort of being a room with the
car.
Yeah.
And these things.
That's the great thing about all car guys.
It's really,
the great thing about Porsche guys is it is this language.
I've had people visit me from all over the world.
Doesn't matter where they speak English,
German or Japanese,
you speak posher and that's that connection and truth be told.
Yeah,
I'm an early air cooled guy,
but also like these,
you know,
high horsepower,
water cooled things.
And to me it's not a case of which is better.
They've both got soul,
but the both slightly different,
but the both got personality.
And to me,
I think that sort of sums up everything.
That was great.
Yeah.
Well James,
you know who resolved,
he's the guy that built your engine and the other half,
well,
the other third of shark works.
Um,
he got to drive to two 77,
you know,
when,
when they went off in the gt two and I was sitting with him and he's a man of
few words and you know,
I just slowly like a few corners in,
you know,
he starts out slowly because it's the two 77 and we were like,
oh,
we're in it.
Um,
so maybe he's getting people his face,
his face is going like this and I just turn around and go,
you're having a good time,
aren't you?
And he's like,
yeah,
you know,
and,
and it's,
you know,
he drives every day,
200,000 or whatever,
150,000,
200,000,
whatever they're worth and build,
you know,
gt three Rs is,
and he gets back in,
uh,
you know,
in your car and he's like,
it's set up nice.
It sounds good.
You know,
it drives properly and he's just having fun in the canyon.
Isn't there something about those old cars to this knowledge that you're in
something from another era and it's almost like a bit of a time machine and
stepping back in time.
Yeah.
Like listening to an old song,
you know,
you,
you listen to like a led Zeppelin song from 1971 and it's like,
there's something about,
it makes you think like,
man,
this was going on.
Like this guy was singing this in a different era.
The world was different and there's a finite number of those cars as well.
They will never,
no one's ever going to build another 1971,
nine 11.
It's just,
it is one of my favorite causes.
My Irish Green 66,
nine 11 and he's pretty much almost in stock form that it would have been in
1966 breaks as well.
Yeah.
What it changed where you know,
obviously it's in you,
but you know the points of my stories,
the costs 49 years old and it's the best way that you just described it,
that I could step back in time to 1966 even though I was born in 1967.
It's like you get in that car and it just,
hey,
it's smell of these early uh,
air called oil cooled nine eleven's you t you know,
I'll go through the process.
You look at it,
site,
walk up to it,
put the key in it tourney,
you sort of feel it and hear it.
Then you sit in it,
put the key in the ignition,
turn the key.
You hear it fire up and then you smell it.
And I said,
time capsule right there.
Yeah,
right.
There is less something modern cars will never give you.
You know,
we've sort of talked for a couple of hours about the difference,
but ultimately if I can home and into,
you know,
five senses of sight,
sound,
smell and feel,
that is the time capsule that I think you just,
soda brought us full circle into what is great about these early air cooled nine
eleven's and truth be told,
it's probably the same thing all the VW guys experience because it is like this
living,
breathing time,
warp time travel entity that ultimately doesn't matter really how fast you're
going.
You just in this zone that is,
yeah,
it's antiquated but it's also pretty excited,
special,
really great.
You know,
you're picking up my car that was,
you know,
from 71 and it's like I'm on the road,
in rush hour traffic,
you know,
things whizzing by me in a bright yellow,
it was like an IRS clone and I'm sitting there,
I've got no AC,
no,
no nothing,
no cup holders,
nothing.
I mean,
and I'm just,
you know,
stinking up the place.
But I loved it,
man.
It was just great.
You know,
just,
and then I got home,
I would take a canyon road near me and it,
I mean
my wife always says Karen,
you know,
when I get home and I've been in a nine 11,
she can tell up being,
and I love a smell.
You sort of come in smelling whether it,
you know,
he's got all those sorta sweat and oil and fuel smell.
I mean,
yeah,
either love it or you don't really,
you know,
it's an acquired taste for sure.
But uh,
you know,
[inaudible] number five for us,
right.
And we drive one of those old carburetor driven car.
Any even an old muscle you smell?
Sure.
Well,
always the leaky carburetors.
I mean,
James helped me rebuild the carbs on mine and it's like,
I spent like three days on it,
you know,
rebuilding the carbs on that engine.
I put him in or he helped me and it's like,
son of a bitch,
I could still smell leaks,
you know?
And it's like,
he's like,
watch this,
how it is,
you know?
And then in the three days that I'd,
I'd taken them out and rebuilt them.
The weather,
it changed like 15 degrees,
you know,
and the car ran like shit,
I just couldn't handle it.
So it's like back to the drawing board
joke about it.
If not only nine 11 is not leaking oil,
there's no oil in it.
These things all sort of living,
breathing,
you know,
pieces of machinery that have got sole on it.
That's what your 1965 but with the new,
with these ones that you've built yourself,
has there been new technology that allows those things to be a little bit more
reliable,
have less issues?
Most of the cars that I built out,
the SDR or you know,
being involved in the process of these,
cause I'm,
I'm still sort of keeping them period correct and I'm not putting new emote is
in those old cars.
You know,
you touched on a little bit what singing is doing,
you know,
the differences.
They're taking a nine six four and sort of back dating it to resemble an old car
with modern technology for the most part,
other than update in fob what I do,
a torsion bars and stiffer suspension,
which yes,
newer components,
but yet it's still running for the most part,
the original motor that's being rebuilt.
Maybe the highest SPEC,
but it's still,
if it was carborated then it's probably still carborated now.
So who,
what about gasket technology or any of those things?
I mean,
have there been improvements and,
yeah,
for sure.
But you know,
he's still,
you know,
it's like right now I'm building a 67 acids,
a car that have got the louvered fenders,
which is my followup bill to the SDR.
I sourced the 67 s case and bought some new Molly Pistons and cylinders.
And as crazy as this story sounds,
I'm shipping all the components to my buddy Matthias,
who's got a shop in Hamburg,
Germany,
and I'm going to have him build the moat or assemble the motor in Germany and
ship it back so it'll have new components in it and it's going to be punched out
from two liter to two five but it's still a 67 ass motor going in 1967 so isn't
that something that Porsche is doing now?
They have like an entire factory dedicated to rebuilding old cars to Porsche
classic restoration facility.
They've actually had for some time.
But what's happened recently over the past three to five years is,
you know,
these cars have just escalated and value to the point where now a lot of these,
cause that let's say would have been trashed five years ago because it wasn't
worth spending 50 grand to restore car that might be worth 30 now that grand
coal or a hundred grand cold could be worth triple that.
What's the name of the Porsche restoration facilities drove the Porsche classic
restoration facility.
Porsche classic recipe.
Yeah,
Porsche classic.
It's amazing though.
I've visited,
uh,
you know,
over the past two years,
I've done various events with Porsche.
I went to the techno classic is show an Esam with them.
I went to the old time of GP at the Nurburgring and Goodwood revival.
Yeah,
that's it.
So the great thing about Porsche is they've got 50,000 parts in the showcase of
Porsche classic let's not just three 56 is,
it's all the way up to the a nine,
nine three facts replacement parts.
It's also a great thing about Porsche in that they make new parts for their old
cars.
They continue to make parts for every single model.
That's why there's so many of them on the road.
They say these 80% of them still on the road.
It's incredible how many cars or 40 year old cars are on the road.
I mean,
well there's companies like year one that make parts for for old muscle cars and
things along those lines.
But there's very few.
I mean,
truth be told,
jags got its own thing.
Jag,
Jaguar has got the heritage facility where they're actually rebuilding 12 of
those.
A continuation lightweight eat types.
I know for,
I know Miss Sadie's as been doing it for quite some time.
Those old cars.
I like that.
Yeah.
Those are the nine five nines.
Do you know the story of the nine five nine in America?
How you can drive on?
Do you know why he can drive one in America?
Cause Bill Gates bought two of them.
I crashed one of them to do the testing,
which is hilarious.
If you want to get one of those,
you'd probably go to [inaudible].
I mean it's,
I mean,
how much are those worth?
I mean that's gotta be worth like nine to now $1 million car.
And couple of years ago they were like,
well I remember when the were two 53 meanwhile if you drove that and then drove
your car back to back and go like fuck this.
Like I said,
I drove how prototype nine five the Brumos zone.
Really you?
I was no different to any of the nine 11.
And it wasn't this brutally just crazy car that they built the gt two,
which he's just not snapping Lee brutally fast.
The nine five nine is not like that.
I mean you've got to remember that how old that car is now.
Eighties,
right?
Yeah.
86.
It was actually designed,
it was,
you know,
I kind of compare it a bit too [inaudible] on a round that over each other too
much for people.
I take a bathroom break.
Yeah.
But what it did was it,
um,
it basically was designed to get to 200.
It was like the first,
you know,
supercar to kind of do that.
Right.
So like the bay run,
so it wasn't brutally fast,
but it was able to,
you know,
to go 200 back in 1986 which was a big deal.
It was one of their first four wheel drive cars too,
right?
Yeah.
Well yeah,
it was,
it had a lot.
Yeah.
All wheel drive.
All wheel is four wheels.
Like he ha,
yeah,
there's a cool picture or I don't know if you ever,
do you know about the Perry Dakar Rally for example?
I've heard of it.
So you should check it out.
People die every year and they go across Africa and,
and they actually took,
they took nine,
five nines,
you know,
and to like,
Roffman's
stuff on it.
You know,
it's a cigarette company.
They raised him,
put knobby tires.
So the nine,
five,
nine perry.cards.
You check it out.
So it's a nine five,
nine and they rallied,
raced across Africa and you know,
it did really well.
Stasiak another iconic nine five nine is so ridiculous.
They take [inaudible],
which is worth $1 million and they sold back then it wasn't truck.
Yeah,
but it's,
but they raced it.
That's Porsche.
That's why they're not actually,
racing is very strange because the cars look so odd.
Jacked up with the,
you know,
they have to have a lot of suspension travel,
so yeah.
Yup.
They have to and they have crazy toys.
It just seems wrong though.
Yeah.
It was wrong to take those cars and to put them with such a wacky suspension
then drive him over dirt.
When you watch,
when you watch them all their like but the footage from the seat,
oh my God,
the guy I'm worried about the navigator though,
the guy reading the,
you know,
left big bulls and always get blamed too when they crashed.
It's like it's shocking your fault.
Google up Pike's peak all Vonda no row voltarol and just see those guys.
I knew that a big fan of the idea of a navigator,
I think you should be forced to fucking drive and have gps then.
So what I,
you know,
I feel like you should be able to figure out every turn if you go off the side
of the cliff,
that's parcel,
you know we were talking about this program called called grand stand,
which um,
you know on a,
on a Saturday afternoon in England on one of the three available channels and
they had this,
have you watched any,
I love man racing before as this crazy fucking bike guys.
Yeah,
those guys.
We had a series with these site cars where these guys would like trapeze off the
side of the bike.
Right.
That's all they did.
But they would be the first ones to let go flying when the thing crashed.
I mean it was just into a wall.
Pretty gnarly.
Gnarly Shit.
Huh?
The island man,
tt is the true test of big bulls in a real hero when he see what those guys,
those
guys,
one down side.
No,
no,
no real heroes there.
They're fighting.
They're fighting for our country or some freedom to go fast and I'm ordering
cycle.
Yeah.
Those guys are animals.
There's something really crazy about someone who wants to raise for a living and
they're like,
McConkie guys,
you know that shortly.
Conky guy for example,
they're just nuts.
What was the,
the,
the um,
the movie that,
the recent Formula One movie with Thor with the fuck is rush,
rush,
rush.
Yeah.
Well that was my era growing up in the 70s you know,
England in [inaudible] 76 77 James Hunt,
one of the [inaudible] and Barry Sheene superbike title.
So that movie didn't get nearly enough respect.
That was a good movie.
Was Ron Howard's movie on racing?
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
I mean,
my mom remembers it differently cause she,
she fancy James Hunt.
A lot of people did those guys.
That was the sex drugs,
rock and roll era of,
you know,
padding,
the lifestyle,
the glamorous lifestyle.
Now he's a whole different thing.
I mean the guy's a faster the cause it quick,
but it's a whole different corporate mentality.
Look a F1 footage in the 70s and people are practically bare feet smoking in the
pits.
Look,
how are these,
these
Thor really does look like.
That guy has got the sticker on the GT two.
Oh yeah.
So yeah.
You know,
remember?
Uh,
yeah,
last time when we were,
when we came here with the four one,
you know,
we showed up at Leno's place and damage rang a Hesketh tee shirt and then we
showed up right to his place.
That's how we met.
We went off to traffic and he's like Hesketh and he's like,
you guys are all right.
That's good.
This heskes in the movie like that you're watching,
you know,
Lord Hesketh,
he was the,
uh,
you know,
financier for,
for James Hunt.
You got to get your car to Seinfeld,
you gotta have that nut drive your car cause he's got one of the best Porsche
collections in the world.
I mean,
he's a real Porsche aficionados seen that show cars,
cars getting coffee.
Yeah.
It's pretty,
it's pretty bad advice as a legit 1972 RS.
It's worth over a million dollars and he drives it on the street.
Yeah,
I know.
Which is,
it was,
it wasn't there,
wasn't there some a swell idea yet backed into it,
right?
Recent did.
Really?
Yeah.
In New York.
So in New York.
Yeah.
They packed into it.
It's like,
oh,
and they didn't probably had no idea it was worth a million.
Now there's like some old stinky Porsche.
Yeah,
that's what it looks like.
A bunch of ugly decals on it.
Dripping oil,
pearls.
Someone backed up into it hard.
Is it fucked up?
[inaudible] right.
There's video of it out there.
I guess you could do a Jerry Seinfeld,
Doris getting rear ended videos.
It's getting hit.
Yeah.
Oh No.
Yep.
I want to see how he reacts.
Paranoia.
What are you doing?
It's almost like you didn't even know him was there.
He's like Gerry,
set right up
when you were first Tyrone.
Things come from behind Ya.
Yeah.
I don't know why anybody would want to spend $1 million on that car.
I don't understand why to put it when it was at 50 grand car.
I'm telling you right there.
Hamptons.
Oh,
oh,
sorry.
Oh my God.
Unapologetic Hampton's woman.
Yeah.
Now do you Jerry impression right now?
Do you even know what you just did?
Hi.
Why do you see how happy he looks there?
He looks really happy.
Is that the before or the guy that's the before shot.
While he watches.
Come on.
Is there a video?
There was a video.
There you go.
Interview.
Let's hear this.
This video is going to get a lot of ways.
He's now.
He says,
oh,
he doesn't look happy there it does.
He,
I wonder if he finally swears to,
this is the great thing about the Internet with talking about it and there it
is.
There it is.
Is there a video of it?
Look cut there.
Yeah,
but that's a video of Seinfeld right there.
No,
no.
Those are photos.
Hey,
what are you doing?
Look at what you're backing into my car.
Hunchback Twat.
Look at her
backing up and it was car.
How do you know you can't see your face to the 456,000 what year was this
correct?
14 that's the problem.
That's the other problem with the Internet.
Everyone has a fricking opinion.
Scrolling down for video,
where's the video?
I saw the video.
I saw,
I was saying,
I don't know where it is,
but maybe he took it down,
baby.
Yeah,
but it says scroll down for video and the article also Combo getting you read on
that.
Funny.
You're go into the daily mail,
which is a British tabloid.
That's British tabloid Daily mail.co.
Dot.
UK.
Isn't that what that you did you guys give us that fucking,
the guy from CNN,
what's his name?
Oh,
that household,
is that from the Daily Mail?
Yeah,
he's uh,
he,
well,
I don't want to say anything.
He's close.
He's a,
yeah,
he's not a very nice chap and cal.
And that's the,
that's the problem with the other problem with the u s like,
it's sort of like the British rejects.
Well,
no,
hold on,
hold on here.
[inaudible] come on.
Ricky's grant.
Look a lot of great comics.
He was not great.
I felt really embarrassed being British with him.
No,
no,
but that piers guy,
well here's guy got it
owned by Chelsea handler.
You ever see that with Chelsea?
No.
You got owned by Alex Jones and the gun stuff and by Ted Nugent.
Oh yeah.
But Chelsea handler,
who's a standup comic just fucking destroyed,
cause she was like,
you're not even paying attention to me.
Like [inaudible] during the commercial break.
You just go over and look at your phone.
Like he's,
he's a fucking moron.
I didn't enjoy him on that show.
I thought he was just,
first of all,
I don't enjoy his background.
I mean,
he was a of people,
not just a shyster.
They tapped into people's phones.
That's not cool.
Why top that were missing.
And they hacked into these people's phones and listened to their voicemail.
And so the parents got a false sense of like,
oh,
they might be still alive checking their voicemail.
And it was because these shitheads we're tapping into the phone.
He was a part of all that.
And somehow or another he escaped.
That's where I'm saying,
you know,
it was easy for him to get in and to impress and get it into the u s and they
didn't really do a proper background check on him.
And then suddenly you became,
you know,
a celebrity over here.
We got rid of him pretty quick.
But I'm glad.
Welcome.
He was shamed many times before.
I mean people got to know what a shithead he is,
but also we,
we are a sucker for an English accent.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
And that was my story come in almost 30 years ago now the monkeys throw come
rolling quite a long way.
But no,
see you don't understand.
We don't know that that's a northern accent.
We have no idea because just anyone who speaks [inaudible] stock and two smoking
barrels,
you know,
and that will sort of tell you all about the great north south divide.
Yes,
great guy.
Ritchie's best movie real love it Love Guy Ritchie.
Huge Fan.
But the funny thing is about,
sorry about Piers Morgan again,
is that if you,
you know,
if you watch top gear a lot,
he's like the butt of every joke.
Like anytime there's anything nasty or disgusting,
you know,
you watch,
um,
you know,
Jeremy Clarkson compare like a car suspension to piers Morgan,
banging him in the rear and he's like Moolah,
you know,
so he's,
he's really not liked.
He shouldn't be,
you know,
that the thing that they did pull it guys for being British.
Yeah.
The thing that they did,
what's happening to people's phones.
It's just awful.
Just disgusting.
And the fact that he snuck in,
but it's like we are,
we are a weird sucker for English,
which is why
those infomercials when they're trying to sell you my favorite thing,
it's always an English thing.
It's always the villains in the Hollywood movies or the cleaning product guy.
It's like,
what would be a cleaning?
Can we do anything else other than mess portion?
David Beck come over here.
Come on.
English guys told them at courses.
That's right.
He didn't know.
Yeah,
we're here.
We get spice girls.
Come on.
Yeah,
a little while,
but we don't give a fuck about soccer.
You can try all day and we're not going to,
we did try with debt or rugby or cricket.
Rugby would be,
would have been a better fit.
That's a man's game is more manly than even the very close to where I can
football.
I think if you took American football players and took the helmets,
Wayne made him play rugby.
That's a more exciting game now.
She had just got one of my concussions from rugby because I played a lot of,
it was a posh man's game.
Rugby it,
you know,
it's very thuggish.
It's a very thuggish game.
I mean you,
it's the only game I know of where a big Samoan,
you know,
it can like step on your teeth in a scrum and then he'll give you his hand to
pick you up.
It's just bizarre,
you know?
And they've got studs on the bottom of those shoes.
Well he's not good at.
Yeah.
So and,
and you don't wear it cricket as well?
I really didn't.
I didn't like that.
Minton no,
no,
no.
Just just rugby.
Roger.
Exactly.
And um,
you know,
you can,
you don't wear any pads.
There's kit when you're,
when you're like 12,
it's scary when you're a small guy and you're the last line of defense as I
wasn't fast at fullback or wing and you know,
at 12 the differences between certain nations,
cause there'll be schools from,
from Tonga and Samoa and New Zealand and they were like big gnarly guys.
And some of them definitely weren't 12 they'd like reset a few years.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Man.
These sandbags.
And they were just,
no,
no one's checking id.
Yeah.
But literally,
you know,
they would,
they would pull acts you and pick you up so you'd have all these and then the
pro,
they weren't,
it wasn't a professional game back in the 80s and you would have these,
they'd have real jobs.
Like there were lawyers because they were pushed that you don't even play that
in a posh school.
Um,
this doesn't happen in chef.
No,
it doesn't.
No.
And suddenly,
you know,
you'd know he's a rugby player cause he's my missing teeth and teeth.
He's a lawyer with missing teeth,
but drinking or like,
yeah,
yeah.
Cabbage years.
Yeah.
I mean Holly flower when you guys called Kabbage years.
Yeah,
we call them cabbages.
Cauliflower.
Cabbage juice is under those headphones.
No,
he's gotten paid ones.
He wears headgear.
Yeah,
I wear,
I wear headgear when I,
you're smart dude.
Jujitsu.
I have a little bit of martial arts background.
I mean,
I remember seeing you on these UFC fights that go around with my buddies and
wash and members senior on fear factor.
And I've heard all about these black belts,
but I don't really know the,
your story.
I started martial arts when I was a little kid.
And you grew up,
I grew up in Boston mostly being in town.
Right?
Fighting around.
Yeah.
Beantown going back there next weekend
minus one.
Right now I think it is their buddy that used to run a store there called Alstom
be in Allston.
Oh,
okay.
Awesome.
Great.
And then,
and moved it to Newbury street.
My Buddy Craig and I owns all the g Newbury street.
It's like the heart of fashion,
right?
Newbury comics.
Right.
We used to sell our storage in the Newbury comics.
Yeah.
You grow up in Beantown.
Mikey mock or I don't know,
Marky Mark Cuban.
I didn't know the Funky funky button.
We have a Saffie Saffie right.
It's like worked in south.
I used to teach a,
I used to be one of the trainers at the Boston Athletic Club.
I actually got to do,
you know Bobby auras famous hockey player.
How dare you.
Neither one of you fucks.
Marky mark portrayed in that film.
That was Boston sorta heroes that you guys make.
You make it more board.
Who's an excellent boxer?
Um,
so,
uh,
I worked in South Boston,
edit this a place called the Boston Athletic Club.
I was probably 19.
I got to meet,
oh,
martial arts.
I start fighting when I was 15.
That's when I got like really into it.
And I was,
I was finding in the men's division when I was 16 kicking ass,
I was doing well,
no,
I wasn't really,
uh,
you know,
I was scared more than I was like ma aggressive and mean.
I was just,
I,
I get into martial arts because I was worried about,
you know,
people kicking my ass.
I just didn't know how to fight.
You want to start figuring out the ability to define yourself,
tired of being scared of everybody.
So,
uh,
I was a four time Massachusetts state taekwondo champion.
I won that four years in a row.
I won the US Open and won a bunch of national tournament's.
Then I started kickboxing.
I did,
but I started doing that as I was doing standup comedy and um,
I,
I stopped competing and then you gotta understand that you just a funny kid in
the neighborhood of my friends,
my friends talked me into it guys that I used to train with actually my friend
Steve Graham,
but I'm still buddies with to this day.
So it wasn't like you failed the new kids on the block,
go audition and figure it out,
go to stem it up.
I didn't even think it was funny.
I thought they thought it was funny cause they were my friend but other people
were just going to think I was an asshole because my sense of humor was just
laughing because he thought that you kicked their ass.
So he was just generally pretty,
I would do impressions of our friends like having sex or doing weird shit.
You know,
I w I was good at impressions,
so do these impressions of people that we knew and I would make people laugh in
the locker room and my friend Steve was like,
you should really be a fucking comedian.
And I was like,
look,
you think I'm funny because you know me,
we just missed,
he made them laugh in the locker room.
Had we not pick up on that what we're getting ready to fight.
Think case gallows humor as well.
It was essentially everybody was nervous and I would be the icebreaker because
we would have sparring days,
like especially on Saturdays.
Saturday was a scary day because we would do what we call team training and team
training was all the black belts would get together and they would pat up and we
would do these really long training sessions and they were brutal and everybody
would shit their pants and the locker room.
So I would be making everybody laugh.
I would be like the,
I express.
That must be,
I don't know
what's scarier there,
like a fight or a standup.
I mean that both of me scarier.
Well physically,
but I mean,
yeah,
it's way scarier in all of the above.
The law of lives are way more devastating than the Joe Rogan story.
Past that point though.
So I still find,
I started doing standup comedy.
I stopped competing,
um,
somewhere around 97,
which is several years later.
I'm still training doing like fairy Smartsheet now while you still buy.
I've got an a la in 94,
[inaudible] 96 I started doing Jujitsu,
so 97,
97,
I started working for the UFC and then I got really into Jujitsu then.
So,
um,
I,
from 96 to today I've been doing two different types of Jujitsu and g and Nogi
meaning with,
uh,
with,
with the call Kimono,
which was like a,
you know,
like a karate uniform and it's like what?
Thicker a jumper.
Yeah.
You throw people around with that and you can grab it,
you could choke them within and see,
you could use it more like it,
it's almost like a weapon.
And then Nogi which is essentially just close.
You don't grab people's clothes,
no clothes.
You're wearing like a skin tight,
a rash guard.
And it's all about a wrestling techniques like under hooks and over hooks and
submission holds and stuff like that.
And so he's still fighting today.
I still know,
I just trained.
I mean,
I don't fight fighting,
you know,
competing is a very different thing.
Obviously you got to,
I mean,
you're competing in the gymnasium,
you go in your sparring.
I mean,
you're going 100% trying to choke each other.
Uh,
but it's a big difference between that and going into competition.
I,
I am of the opinion that especially fighting like MMA,
you should not do that unless that's all you're doing.
I think blackline and that it should be 100% of your focus because if it's not,
I think it was just wanting to someone and it is 100% of them.
They're gonna fuck you up.
So if you're out for a real spur to drive,
oh,
you're on the track.
If you're not 100% folk,
don't be texting.
Yeah,
don't be texting when you are a car.
So when did MMA and UFC sort of really exploding takeover the thunder of box and
what was that 10 years ago?
Five years ago?
About 10 years ago.
It took off because the ultimate fight are those 2005 when I came along,
I came along in [inaudible] 97 I was the post fight interview or this was like a
long before it was big.
We used to fly into places like Dothan,
Alabama and do these shows and these little,
what is your school?
But you know if you're watching him,
this is you.
We just had UFC one 82.
Wow.
So,
uh,
the next one's one 83 I believe,
which is,
makes a lot of events where you'd been with them as soon as five one no,
12 I came along and you have to see 12 but I only worked for them for two years.
It was in different organization,
different people owned.
It worked for him for two years and then it was just getting too crazy.
They were banned from cable.
It was really like more of a blood sport image.
Like people didn't understand what it was.
No,
it had rules,
but it was just the,
the,
the public perception of it.
Like I would tell people that I worked with that I was going some youtube back,
y'all brule,
and it was like I was doing porn.
That was the attitude.
They're like,
why are you doing that?
Like what are you going
to ruin your career?
But today 193 fights later today is much different,
much different.
I started working for the UFC again at UFC 37 and a half,
which was in 2002 and you've done a mold since then have to most of them.
Well,
most of the paper views,
but there's so many events now.
I can't do them all.
Like there's Fox sports,
one events,
which most of I I'm doing the one next weekend.
But most of those I don't do.
And then there's fonts and sometimes you can,
he does them.
He's going back and forth about Porsche's with me on,
on,
on the interweb crazy guys.
The,
I'm sort of loosely sort of seeing visually that we're involved with,
uh,
what was the guy's name?
Dana Sunday.
Yeah.
He's the president of KFC and they were from,
well they have the beach guy.
Dana's from Boston and back in the day?
No,
I didn't know him until 2002 I met him when I was doing fear factor because the,
that fear factor start 2002 I think in 2001 2002 somewhere on.
How'd you go from being this Bostonian martial arts commuting guide?
A fear factor.
How does that,
I was on a Sitcom before that.
I was on a Sitcom on NBC called News Radio and that was on for five years in the
90s and you've come out to La to do the acting stand up.
Then I came out to La for another show called hardball that was on Fox that was
cancelled.
I got hired to the shows that it was a baseball show,
like a Sitcom about baseball that was canceled after like six episodes and I was
out here.
I already leased an apartment for a year,
so I was like,
ah,
fuck.
I'm stuck here for awhile.
I wanted to go back to New York.
Was this a bit like swing news?
One of my old time favorite movies,
like sweating.
In what way?
You know,
just people coming out to La to pursue acting.
And did you wear Mickey mouses killed for that role?
There was a lot of that skinny vins foreign.
You look at Vince Vaughn and swingers and you're looking at it on the day
different John fabree go a lot of booze,
food,
living the good life.
A lot of miles,
a lot of miles.
So how are you fall into fear factor?
How does that,
uh,
it was the same casting director that worked with NBC for uh,
news radio.
He just brought me in.
They were mostly interviewing like sports announcers and people.
They wanted it to be like serious.
And when I came in for the audition,
I was actually mocking it.
I was laughing at it and they thought it was terrible for the job because I was
mocking it.
And then somehow they realize like,
look,
if we don't mock it,
someone else better to have our own guy it as it's happening.
Can I just take it slash yeah,
go ahead.
It's fine.
I just thought it was ridiculous.
You know,
you're sick dogs on people.
This is the most ridiculous show idea of all talented.
That showroom for it just seemed like six years,
148 episodes,
and then we came back and did another seven until uh,
we did an episode where people had a drink come,
they had a drink,
coffee come
and that's what got to cancel.
TMZ found out about it.
They put the images on fucking giant beer.
Stein of donkey come.
Oh,
and the public outrage was,
but NBC was fine with it.
They had greenlit it.
They'd say,
they said that we could have the purple drink come.
How bad could it be?
Well,
it was,
you know what man,
these people,
they,
everyone wants to push the envelope and what are you going next?
Because they keep pushing and pushing and pushing.
Until finally they,
they don't even realize how far they've crossed the line until other people
react realities.
Blood.
Well,
I was telling them not to do it.
I mean,
when I'm telling you that it's a bad idea,
something wrong here.
There was two times when we did that show where I told people don't do it.
What was the other one?
Bull riding.
Yeah.
They made people ride bulls and I said,
this is a fucking bad idea,
man.
Because you're dealing with,
uh,
an uncontrollable environment.
You're dealing with an animal,
you know,
I don't care if you think it's tame.
That's not tame.
It's a bowl.
Just because you were corralled it and you figured out a way to rope it or put
it in a cake,
that's not a tame thing.
Tame as a cat.
You go up to the kitty cat and repetitive purrs.
It knows your person close rubs up against your leg.
That's a tame animal.
A dog's a tame out bowls are never fucking 10.
Yeah,
there will always fuck you up.
You don't want holes never come up to you to get pet.
You know,
they'll fucking stick their horn right up your ass and launch you over the top
of the arena.
They don't give a shit,
you know?
I mean,
we've all seen those images of a bull gorgeous.
The one where it goes through the guy's chin out his mouth.
It's like,
that is in my mind.
Why you should never fucking bull fight like that.
All run with the Bulls are,
oh,
that's the most ridiculous thing.
That's a real,
they say the thrill of running with the bulls like the fuck are you talking
about?
My,
the animals with testosterone,
giant balls and they're angry and they're running down these wet blood and
fucking beer soaked streets.
Everything's cobblestone and slippery.
And you're running to get away from these fucking balls.
Oh
No,
I,
no,
I haven't done it.
I've seen it.
Why is this one the concussions,
Ashley?
No,
you got a lot of stories.
These guy,
you've actually had a,
um,
well I've got a couple of podcasts lined up.
Um,
there's a doctor that's on there,
Dan told me about it cause he heard him,
but he's very into concussions.
And Rhonda,
Patrick,
that's him.
Yeah,
her,
sorry.
Rhonda.
Him that's on the shelf.
Well,
Rhonda,
man,
I've talked about transvestites earlier,
so,
well,
no,
she's a woman,
but she,
um,
I took her to a UFC and uh,
her husband is a,
he's a fan of it and I don't think she had ever watched it before.
Actually,
I dunno does Dan,
I don't know if he was a fan,
but anyway,
I,
I invited them cause they live in northern California.
So they came to the UFC and it's the first time she had ever seen it.
She literally had no idea what it was all about.
And after it was over she was like,
oh my God.
And then she went deep on the show into the dangers of head trauma and all
that's going on.
Yeah.
I think,
was that the one that I was at where Anthony Johnson knocked a out?
Um,
I would say that was an og.
Yeah,
that was brutal.
Nogueira yeah,
it felt,
yeah,
that was,
that's probably the headache the next day.
Oh,
probably still.
Probably still to this day.
It probably gets up if you saw that.
I mean it was,
it was actually,
I wish they'd stopped it sooner,
but yeah.
Well it was at one round knockout him.
It's pretty quick.
I mean it was just,
he tagged them a couple times and then put them away.
Yeah.
Johnson's fighting for the number one title contention next,
not next weekend,
but the weekend after that in Sweden.
Who is the big top dog guy now John Jones was number one,
just tested positive for cocaine.
Oops.
Oopsy daisy.
See oopsy daisy rehab.
People like to pause an amazing fighter.
Amazing fighter.
Yeah.
He's a crazy reach.
Pretty arguably the best ever at this point in time.
And he's only 27 wow.
My favorite.
Those Nick Diaz.
I love Nick Diaz fighting in a couple of weeks.
That's riding on January 30th in Vegas.
Anderson Silva.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
30th or 31st.
Now remember that name Nick?
Yeah.
Nick Diaz is,
he's just like personality.
Well No,
no,
no.
He's from Stockton.
I don't think so.
No.
No,
but he's awesome to watch fight and he just does it like nobody else stopped in
comp before she goes.
Of course,
I niggas can't park them in front of their house and then sleep.
Sleep.
Yeah.
Everything will be gone window.
And now he's just,
he's a good dude.
Yeah.
That's the problem with things like poor,
like I,
I posted an image of a your car yesterday and somebody wrote,
Oh,
in the comments of Instagram,
you know,
I hate Porsche guys.
They're all show offs.
Like how hilarious is that?
They're all of them,
but it's like,
it disqualifies you from ever owning one because you'll be a douche.
Like you can just enjoy the engineering.
You can do.
Even if he was just by yourself.
There was no one around.
You didn't tell anybody.
He had a Porsche.
You took the edge,
the car carver off it,
and just drove it around deserted road and enjoy the shit out of it.
You can't slip it.
Some people's views,
we'll look at him.
I mean,
I thought he was a rocker.
He looks at Dcb.
Right?
But some people say automate your husband.
Some people automatically associate cars like Porsche's factory a little bit
earlier on.
Especially here in la.
Yeah,
it's an image thing.
Yeah.
You know,
sometimes he's pull shoes.
Don't leave that Bebo Zip code.
You know,
you go,
do you ever take it to the Triton?
No,
I don't want to get it.
Chipped up.
A Guy,
a guy in a Aston Martin repeat and he was definitely an agent.
Definitely in Aa.
Hey,
here's all the wood writes a movie.
Tim knows he looked,
he was looking at his phone and he was on a Bluetooth.
You have a noise.
Well maybe you're an Asian in fact.
And on the toilet.
Oh,
can do on the toilet.
Well there's a lot of agents here so it's probably,
and it was like that time of the day where,
you know,
it's like we should be at work,
but you're not taking,
it's not lunchtime.
So yeah,
he's doing the meeting and the meeting,
well there's image cars and you know,
the,
the big ones are of course Ferrari's,
a big image car,
you know,
that's like the,
probably the most obnoxious,
evolve them in a lot.
The Lamborghini Lamborghini is a big one.
Yeah.
They're so great.
Adjusts and three cap one two for like the Jeremy Clarkson always says,
you know,
like m three drivers are constantly on Bluetooth and that's the big thing,
you know.
Well as Jeremy Clarkson,
I don't know what the fight,
he hates Porsche's tool going to have images.
And I tell this story all the time.
I think anyone grown up anywhere in the world in the seventies or eighties,
chances are if you're a car guy,
he had a choice of one to three posters,
Porsche Turbo,
Lamborghini,
coon,
Tashana probably a Ferrari,
five 12 bucks or a Testarossa.
I had those of WM one.
No Way.
That my way without peanut one.
Yeah,
that was a cool car.
That was it.
47 and we're the same age.
Yeah,
I had that.
I didn't have one.
I had a model of that.
I had like a,
a model of it.
Um,
and it was a bas staff.
Remember that company?
They used to make,
um,
tape tape.
Basically it was a cool car.
The BMW,
BSF tape cardmembers members.
You pull that up,
dude.
You,
since you had that pull up at Vasf,
look at that and you'll be like,
that's a quite one.
But that was a space age,
car day.
But I look at it now,
it looks like those cars racing down the historics.
Unbelievable.
I I'm looking same GP at Norberg ring.
I like 25 of them rolling around the [inaudible] VASF yeah,
look at that thing.
I had that and my mum gave it away to some of them.
I left.
I said thanks a lot mom.
Look at that.
Right.
And you know what and VASF is literally,
you know,
tape tape the tape for Sony Walkman.
Oh really?
That's what I mean by tape.
You know,
I liked the fender flares on that day.
Did you love fenders,
aren't you?
Yeah,
I'm a big fan of what,
one of the things I love about uh,
like Jack Olsen's cause wide body fender flares.
I love those.
I love side to me that see evolution of,
I spoke earlier on about liking the 2002,
I 3.0 CSL Batmobile.
That to me is the evolution allows you liked it.
Nine,
nine three nine meister that a Rsr that they built because people always ask me,
do I like RWB?
I'm a big owl WB fan.
I don't like those.
A car is like the nine Meister Rsr,
like which is essentially like the gt two by body kit gt dude gt two with the,
with the bolt on flare.
Just an image for that nine,
nine,
three Rsr.
Find the nine,
nine,
three to four car man.
Look at the asset or that thing.
Click on that one that we just get a white one.
So you can see the bolted on flares.
Yeah.
Why won't gold wheels,
Oh yeah,
that's,
that's actually not even click on the other one that you were just hovered above
that right there.
Yeah.
That's the one that has the bolt on fender flares.
Oh,
that's a fucking beautiful ass,
right.
That,
that's Jennifer Lopez to me.
But also,
but also it's got Ronda Rousey on a guys fucking tires to Miss God that things
hold up my a STL and we'll see what Joe thinks to that.
Just punching Magnus Walker Seo or something like,
well,
I've seen that car.
I loved that car.
I love the,
uh,
the back end.
And I saw that person got just thing.
We,
uh,
Tiffany to Dell driving it that,
but just go to the toe.
There's a video of tickets.
I saw it.
I'm fifth gate.
So go back to,
remember I spoke earlier on about doing something with Tiffany Odell.
That right there for is uh,
oh.
Let's see that man.
Let me see that for the appropriate audiences.
Oh,
not your
car was not overly um,
um,
horsepower.
It either.
I mean it was a fairly reasonable to Tifton Dell pulling into your drive over at
horrible drive it from downtown all the way up to the snake.
And then he,
if you fast forwarded,
they pulled in.
Was that his truck?
No,
that was uh,
you know,
uh,
Jonathan Ward from icon does the,
Darrell [inaudible].
That's his,
that's his.
Oh Wow.
Have you met him Jonathan Ward?
No.
You got to get him on the show.
We were talking about those cars that he makes yesterday,
that Bronco that he makes the,
I got on the thing and he makes those old cars and they look like old shit
boxes,
but they have incredible suspension unless he's derelicts where he finds those
old beat up Patina Chels and everything underneath these new mechanic.
Yeah.
But he doesn't do anything to the outside.
Well that's what's cool about it.
I don't think,
hey,
it's TIF working it.
He's saying here,
he's saying,
I'm looking for Ronan.
Hey,
same,
where's that gt two.
So they see sort of the inspiration for Alex's shot worx gt two right there a
little bit.
And how fast is this car like?
I mean how many horsepowers his car that he's driving here to 75 and it probably
weighs 2000 pounds.
20 to 50 so all steel know fiberglass on it.
Yeah.
Ah,
well if you wanted to get it lower,
you'd have to go fiberglass.
And how much lower could you get it?
Yeah,
not well,
you could go under 2000 which is magic,
but could you really?
Oh my God.
Why didn't you?
You pretty pretty much just have a all steel steel.
Yeah,
so the only reason why to go all fiberglass would be just for the weight,
but now you go cop.
But that stuff just cracks.
I mean I've had you know,
fiberglass fenders before on wide body,
you know,
old nine 11 it's,
and then it's just not the same.
It craps looks so excited.
This is the car that I sold at the good in your auction at the 50th anniversary
at Pebble beach area.
Do you miss it?
Well,
here's the great thing about it.
I have visitation rights to it and now reside in what I think is the greatest
Porsche collection in the country in Durham,
North Carolina.
I didn't look close.
Prodo tipo steering wheels,
[inaudible] old school.
Momo still blessing all the fat Momo.
Right?
Those are,
I actually,
I've driven this car three or four times in the past year.
Really?
Yeah.
North Carolina drove it down to Fort Bragg and then a in Monterrey.
I shot a video with Patrick Long and this up in Monterey,
so it's cool that I record.
Do you have to build them a new one?
I didn't wreck it.
I mean come on.
Who thinks that if you do,
yeah,
sure I'd take care of.
But you know,
thankfully I've,
I know my limitations it,
you know,
on the road and I never pushed above and beyond them.
Now what about bumper?
Yeah,
just see red pump right there.
Now what about um,
this car doesn't have any spoiler in the back.
There's nothing.
It's just flattened the,
does that become an issue at speed?
Maybe if you're all at willow springs going through turn eight flat out like a
buck 35 four one 40 maybe.
But on the street,
no,
it doesn't make any difference at all.
Like not all share wouldn't aid it in any way.
I mean,
let,
let's say you're on a freeway on a sweep doing 120 530 miles an hour.
Yeah,
maybe then,
but it's still fun sort of having that rear and move around a little bit.
And that's okay when it,
when you need to do that,
you can do it in the water called one with the big off
dash is relentless in his pursuit of water.
Cool.
Except the water.
Cool one.
Interesting little point.
The guy that shot these photos for speed unto Sean cling and half of it,
we're actually going to be doing a photo shoot with him in about an hour in
downtown La.
So really we're meeting him a three.
Cool.
Is that that that was the inspiration for our car and I'm having the same guy,
the same guy shoot it in the same,
oh that's amazing.
So let's just 72,
a nine 11 right there.
And does the louvered,
a deck lid like that,
does that have any function?
I mean it helps style,
but obviously it has coming out of it.
Yeah.
So He's full ma'am.
Function.
I mean,
have you seen,
have you seen as new?
Um,
well it's not even finished.
And it was like one of the coolest talked about cars at Sema this year.
Have you seen the one with the louvered flares?
It was at the moment
on food from Fenn.
Yeah,
two years ago.
So where can I see that?
Is it online?
Yeah,
you can see it online.
It,
what could they look up?
Jamie [inaudible] 67 str.
Let me briefly tell you my seem a story.
I'm sure you're familiar with Magnus Walker 67 this year.
Yeah.
Oh,
just go images minus could 67 s or t SRT SRT.
Magnus Walker.
Yeah,
just put mine in this war.
Oh Dude.
The top down right there.
Right there on the left.
So let me tell you my mobile one story real briefly.
All my sema story.
Two years ago I snuck into Sima on someone else's pass and if you go back to
that this year I got invited by mobile one to display to cause in the booth,
which had three cards.
The other one was a pro touring sorta 67 Camaro.
But that's just how crazy my life had become in the past two years from sneaking
into the Sema Show in Vegas,
which is the biggest sort of aftermarket specialty equipment show to be an
invited by a mobile one or from one documentary?
Yeah.
I never thought that none of this has been scripted.
There's no PR person behind it's men,
an iPhone se.
That's what I enjoy about 99% of the time.
You're a,
there's no agent.
Your shop we made,
the way we met,
um,
is my friend Todd Todd Mesereau who is the producer of my,
a show on Scifi a Todd is a Porsche guy.
He owns a nine,
nine three loves,
loves Porsches.
And uh,
we were talking about you.
I showed him the video,
we'd gone back and forth and he goes,
you know,
we're going to be in downtown next week.
Like let's contact magnets.
Let's go see if we could see his shop.
So he called you,
you answered the phone one time.
You guys had a conversation and we,
after we shot,
we just drove down and hung out with mangoes for a couple hours.
I emailed him right before the Jay Leno show and right after,
and I said,
is it still okay to come right?
And he's like,
yeah,
no,
it was,
it was like Friday at 9:00 PM I arrived there,
but gay opens,
his wife was real happy and uh,
and then he's like,
oh cool man.
Yeah.
I was just reading about it on the cover,
blah,
blah.
And I'm like,
all right,
well go for a ride.
Yeah,
yeah.
You want me to drive it?
So I hear him wailing around,
well,
not wailing,
just puttering around.
Sorry,
putting round in the 4.1 gt three Rs and Dan,
who's in the passenger seat,
you know,
he was telling me later.
Yeah,
he's going like,
uh,
yeah,
just,
just one more lap.
Just one more lap.
And right before he got in the car,
right before he gets in the car,
sorry,
just going to throw you under the bus at bit.
He's talking to his wife Karen,
and going,
Oh,
I've just got some stragglers in that.
The last ones of the day.
I swear,
I'm just kicking them out right now.
You'll just kicking them out.
I'm kicking him out.
I swear I'm coming over right and 70 fricking laps later
I got to throw out a promise to my wife Karen.
I've been with her for over 20 years and uh,
yeah,
that's why I'm the luckiest guy in the world is I've got,
first of all,
she's beautiful.
She's my Georgia Peach and uh,
she just allows me to be this crazy fool sort of,
you know,
enjoying my life.
But uh,
without her,
I don't think we'd be here today.
So,
uh,
you're not hand impact is what you're trying to say.
Ah,
I'm just saying I love my wife and she's super supportive.
What I say,
my wife,
my wife from my birthday before I even had a shot,
this is what she got me was a set of the first Brembo GTR breaks do,
I could put on my really fast turbo and she helped me install nitrous lines when
I was,
you know,
drag racing that's fucking bad ass.
So she,
and she makes video games.
Sorry.
Is there another way to take those naturally aspirated engines and get them to
join a lawyer?
Is Powerful.
Is that 800 horsepower that you have in that gt two?
Is there a way?
I mean,
have we reached the limitations?
no limitations.
Essentially on the air cooled cars.
He gets up to bike before 50 and it's like didn't nine meister get,
oh they got a nine nine three engine up to like 450 horsepower.
I mean it's really pushing a round thing through a square peg,
you know it or whatever there.
I don't think you need a under the horsepower with the early,
uh,
all the election,
whether or not you,
it,
I'm saying is it possible,
I mean,
have you,
I don't think you can get 800,
but then again,
I'm not building of a naturally aspect.
I'm not talking about it early car,
I'm talking about your car that to 4.1 you got up to five 60.
Yeah.
Like what is the limitation?
Um,
so that's an interesting question so you can make more,
but what's the delivery of more?
So we probably,
yeah,
we could,
we could bore and stroke it out to four point whatever we want.
You know what I mean?
Well,
how much 4.34 rehab.
It's,
it's being looked at in the maths being done.
The problem is,
and we've tried certain things who tried,
what happens is the Pistons get larger,
you know,
they get heavier,
then it stops feeling like a gt three and feels like a sloppy VA or Shitty VA.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
because it's more weight in the back.
Well there's more weight.
I mean,
think about Heavier Pistons Balance,
you know,
I mean you can add more displacement,
but how are you going to do that?
There's cost involved in terms of more weight,
more weight is the enemy and a gt three we'll call.
Yeah,
exactly.
You want to be revving part of the thing.
But that 4.1 is that I thought it was still a gt three like you get in it and
it's like,
it's still related.
Like it's related to your three nine.
Oh yeah,
right.
For sure.
Um,
it's like the GT two.
So you could technically make a big,
you know,
I mean the gt two doesn't rev the same way.
You know,
it feels heavy.
It's got heavier,
stronger components in it.
Joe needs to drive to 77 I think it does.
I do.
I think pissed it's raining.
I think you need to drive do and then you probably need an early car in your
stable I think.
And that way you can sort of see how the less is more lightweight,
smaller displacement work,
a little bit harder approached.
Again,
a thrill out of driving is,
and then you'll probably have the best of both world mentor me,
Magnus Walker.
How would just go for a drive.
So we're going to do drive.
You talked about Ah,
Alex and I actually talked about him building me a nine six,
four we talked,
oh that's a thing.
I want to build a lightweight nine seats for us.
Inspired.
Oh,
come to the right.
How light can you get one of those?
They're start out pretty heavy.
They're actually heavier than a nine nine three.
Really?
Why is that?
And it just the time period,
you know they got heavier and heavier,
so a lot of people,
they were sort of hated on a bit.
Now they're really popular because they looked kind of awkward.
They're in a weird middle stage,
which is my end of the road for the early styling.
Moving into the nine nine squared is a fickle on me.
He always likes to say it's full was the unloved nine 11 I mean you could find
them all day long and a 20 grand but now anymore those days of the tables have
turned and the technology was different than a lack of it I should say.
And it,
yeah,
it was just heavier piston heads featured this really,
really nice one.
Recently a white one that was like really radical and cheap history breastfeed.
I'm impressed bringing out the English flag.
He's an eye low file.
Is that what we call them?
We'll data that one that they did do though.
That one nine six four was very nice sex.
It really lightweight.
I think that the license plates had growler or something like that.
The thing that sucks though.
And this is the bus,
my buddy's car [inaudible] call the white one.
Have you driven that car?
Uh,
yes I have it.
What's it like it great car story without punching Alex is cause I got him into
the Porsche owner club and now he's become a really nine six four growler pull
up,
pull up growler.
Oh yeah.
We'll just punch in.
Alex Bermuda's
went back.
Yeah,
he's a local guy.
That's it.
Yeah.
Oh is that your wall?
A No,
it's,
I thought it was just like,
this is a cool guy.
I actually got,
I was his first driving instructor with a Porsche owner club and uh,
he runs a Spec box there.
And uh,
my buddy Tyson Schmidt that used to work at tre built that car and then Alex
bought it from her and did his own customers.
What's that like to drive like one of your lightweight cars or two 77 pumped up,
these sort of,
these stepping stones to me that the in between two 77 and the gt three 3.9 but
as it as tactile as you're [inaudible] 77 yeah,
the whole deal.
The thing that really is faster,
it's fast.
A lot of those cool cars never really made it here.
Like the RS isn't it?
They had like an rs America.
It's not the same.
You know,
we had the one with the big fuck off wing on the back,
you know,
a plexiglass windows and you know,
sort of,
it's a shame in a sense that the state is never gets a lot of these great cars
and [inaudible] 73 hours never really officially came in here.
It is that because of safety regulations and they don't want to crash him I
guess or whatever.
You don't know everyone's Bill Gates or he doesn't want one maybe.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well this is a really interesting conversation and a lot of people,
I'm probably are ignorant to the joys of these lightweight,
exciting cars.
Like what you have and certainly to what you're building these extreme versions
of the,
the race bred nine 11,
you know,
they're,
they're fascinating cars and,
and it's,
uh,
it's a,
a group of people that enjoy them,
that it generates such incredible loyalty and passion.
You know,
it's,
it's really unlike most cars in that sense.
Yeah.
Well we,
I mean you hadn't even,
I'd not even met you.
I,
and the first phone call we pretty much had like,
I was like,
man,
he gets it.
You,
you rattled off all this stuff about gt threes,
you know,
and cause you had the 2010 and I'd had it.
So I'd had that connection and yeah,
you'd watch the video and I pretty much,
you know,
we just kind of riffed for like an hour or so after work.
You and I didn't want to start a brand new car.
That was a story
video.
That's it.
This video.
Well that video of the,
the green,
the Cook Carmen.
And you've never seen that video?
No.
3.9 gt Kermit.
Bear in mind.
It was done on her avid station back before we had high def cameras go,
Joe.
Interested throw up the video.
Got Sick Bitch Porsche versus Ferrari.
That's a good one.
It's smokes.
This,
this not even a stock.
Four,
five,
eight.
It's four 30.
It's been modified with 30.
Yeah.
This was on Saturday.
It was a four 30.
That's the new one.
Yeah.
This was back at Beale air.
They shut down.
This is how great is America.
They shut down Beale air force base so that we could film a TV show with Tanner
Foust and Paul Tracy.
Yeah.
And it was a show called the fuck.
What is she holding that with?
An iPhone?
No,
no,
she's not.
No,
no,
no.
She's doing the editing.
I'm doing the,
the uh,
she's driving Tanner and Tanner's Tanner's driving the green car and pull
Tracey's driving that one.
Look at that shock and we'll spin off that baby.
That's your car baby.
Just the green version of it.
Have 10 or I just saw you posted on names for God and that he's liking the GTTA.
Yeah,
he likes it.
Yeah.
So No.
Yeah,
that's the guy you want driving that fucking thing.
And Chris and Chris Harris.
Did you ever see that?
Yeah.
And Chris Harris Jr but 10 or files is a real race car.
I take a lapse with him.
Dude.
He's,
he's awesome.
Yeah.
A lot of people don't sort of give him credit,
but you know,
cause he's a drift boy or whatever.
But didn't he beat like Michael Schumacher,
race of champions?
I've driven with them
like on the track in my cars that I've built and I didn't even know they could
go that fast.
I didn't know that he wasn't going to use any breaks.
I mean,
he's an animal dude.
Doesn't use breaks.
It just,
just lightly.
Just to set the car up in front of him.
Yeah,
exactly.
I was just like,
you're coming in really fast as a wall right there.
And he says,
yeah,
that's really close.
You know,
as he's turning.
And he just just lightly taps it.
And we're flying around the,
well,
he compresses a suspension so much at the hairpin of Sears point.
And this was for a speed channel that the uh,
the front lip that I had on there,
literally it touched it and it exploded.
It shattered when we thought like we blew a tire and the guy that owns a track
says,
oh,
I've seen that a couple of times on a,
you know,
the cup cars,
and he's doing that on North Street car.
Yeah,
just compression.
How could that be avoided?
Can you not avoid that?
Raise it quite as fast.
You're not have Tanner Foust drive?
I don't know.
Have you ever seen the video on top gear?
The US version where he's taking this corvette,
z o six,
around this industrial area?
That was one of the early ones.
That was one of the Holy Shit.
Wild
animal.
The way that guy drives,
he's super the fuck he's doing.
It's so like precise and surgical.
The way he's taking
corners on that TV show,
it was called battle of the supercars.
It wasn't the world's greatest show,
but like I said,
they shut down a stealth,
you know this where they fly all the UAV is that kill all the terrorists.
That's where the operators,
Beale air force base,
like we weren't even allowed to look at in certain directions and there were
lines with people with guns that would shoot.
They would shoot you if you looked well on it.
Don't look and don't cross.
Don't step over this line.
Right and like secretly drama a little bit.
Yeah.
No,
well no,
I got to,
I got to drive the car with a u two spy plane taking off and I was like the
touch and go car basically and he's like don't get any closer or burn your
fucking paint off.
Yeah,
I would imagine that those jet engines,
yeah,
that's a,
that's a bad ass little ride.
Gentlemen.
We're out of time but this has been a lot of files.
Emotional.
Yes.
People need to watch your documentary if they haven't seen it.
It's urban outlaw.
It's available on Vimeo.
It's beautiful.
It's back deficit.
You're going to want to buy a Porsche.
If you do want to buy a Porsche and you want to get crazy.
If you want to get a a gt three sent it to this guy,
fuck it.
You only live once.
If you can afford to send it the shark work shoes that bitch up and you'll be
flying and no time.
Thank you,
gentlemen.
Really appreciate it.
You are fun.
Magnus Walker's on Instagram.
Shark works on Instagram and shark works.
Uh,
W E R K s on Twitter and Instagram.
Gentleman.
Always pleasure.
Good Times.
Get that fucking shark drive.
Get Out.
Well,
thanks for three hours.
I'm pretty quick right there.
Thank you brother.